I THANK YOU FOR GOOD FOR BEING
PATIENCE AND GOOD AFTERNOON WE
WANNA WOULD LIKE TO CONVENE THE
ASSEMBLY COMMITTEE ON
COMMUNICATIONS AND CONVEYANCE --
NOTICING THE ABSENCE OF A QUORUM
[inaudible]
POLITICAL.
WE NOW HAVE A QUORUM --
MADAM SECRETARY --
PLEASE CALL ROLL [inaudible]
SANTIAGO [inaudible]
HERE [inaudible]
OBERNOLTE [inaudible]
BONTA [inaudible]
CERVANTES [inaudible]
EDUARDO GARCIA [inaudible]
HOLDEN [inaudible]
KAMLAGER-DOVE LOW [inaudible]
MAIENSCHEIN [inaudible]
MATHIS [inaudible]
PATTERSON [inaudible]
QUIRK SILVA [inaudible]
RODRIGUEZ.
WITH A QUORUM WILL NOT BEGIN.
I BEFORE YOU START ONE READ SOME
GROUND RULES ON THAT WHEN WE HAD
A OBSERVING TODAY [inaudible]
ON AFTER THE AUTHOR PRESENTS I
WILL AFFORD AYE TEN MINUTES OF
TESTIMONY FOR THOSE IN SUPPORT
OF THE BILL.
AND ASK THAT YOU LIMIT OR
SUGGEST THAT YOU LIMIT YOUR
TESTIMONY OF EACH INDIVIDUAL FOR
NO MORE THAN TWO MINUTES PER
PERSON.
OR LESS TO ALLOW THE MOST
PARTICIPATION A LOT AND IT IN
THE TIME FRAME SO.
I'LL REMIND EVERYBODY --
IRRESPECTIVE WHAT SIDE YOU'RE ON
WHEN YOU HIT THE TWO MINUTES YOU
CAN.
DECIDE TO CONTINUE CERTAINLY I'M
NOT ENCOURAGING YOU DIG TO GET
TO TWO MINUTES --
BUT NONE THE LESS.
I WILL THEN ALLOW THOSE WHO
SUPPORT WHO DID NOT TESTIFY TO
ENTER THEIR NAMES INTO THE
RECORD.
OFFER THOSE PEOPLE WILL WE WILL
ONLY ALLOW --
AND LIMIT THEIR TESTIMONY FOR
THEIR NAME AFFILIATION AND
POSITION.
AND WE'LL DO THAT FOR EVERY
PERSON.
AND I'LL REMIND YOU FOR NOT.
THEN AFTER THE TEN MEN AND THEN
WILL ALLOW TEN MINUTES
PROPOSITION.
AGAIN WE'LL BE ASKING YOU LIMIT
YOUR TESTIMONY TO NEWMAN NO MORE
THAN TWO MINUTES.
ARE OR LESS TO ALLOW THE MOST
PARTICIPATION POSSIBLE --
THEN I WILL ALLOW THOSE IN
OPPOSITION WHO DID NOT THE GET
THE TESTIFIED THERE AND THEIR
NAME INTO THE RECORD AGAIN.
JUST THEIR NAME AFFILIATIONS AND
POSITION IT WILL REMIND
EVERYBODY WHEN WHEN YOU'RE
STEPPING OUT OF THAT THAT BOUNCE
JUST TO BE FAIR.
TO ALL SIDES AND EVERYONE --
I APPRECIATE YOUR PATIENCE IN
THE PROCESS AND THANK YOU VERY
MUCH WOULD LIKE --
TO WE'D LIKE TO BEGIN WITH S. B. --
EIGHT TWO TWO ON I
COMMUNICATIONS BROADBAND
INTERNET SERVICE ACCESS --
MISTER WEINER WOULD LIKE TO
BEGIN I THANK YOU VERY MUCH
MISTER CHAIRMAN AND I JUST TO
CLARIFY THE TEN MINUTES I AM
ASSUMING DOES NOT INCLUDE MY
STATEMENT.
OKAY UP.
WE WILL LET THE AUTHOR PRESENT
WE WILL ALLOW TEN MINUTES IN
SUPPORT AND TEN MINUTES IN
OPPOSITION.
I STRONGLY RECOMMEND THAT THAT
ANY IN SUPPORT.
I WOULD ONLY GO TWO MINUTES --
TWO MINUTES EACH TO ALLOW FOR
THE MAXIMUM AMOUNT OF
PARTICIPATION THANK YOU VERY
MUCH AT ALL HOBBIES ARE
REASONABLY BRIEF ARE MISTER
SHARON.
I UNDERSTOOD CHAIRMEN ARE
COLLEAGUES THANK YOU FOR HEARING
THIS OP BILL TODAY AND FIRST SO
I WANNA.
I JUST REALLY STRESSED MY
GRATITUDE TOWARDS THE CHAIRMAN --
AND TO HIS STAFF OF COMMITTEE
AND OFFICE STAFF --
FOR WORKING AYE AYE REALLY
DILIGENTLY METHODICALLY WITH US
OUGHT -- TO
COME UP WITH THE BILL THAT IS
BEFORE THE COMMITTEE --
TODAY AND SOMEONE ACCESS
PUBLICLY EXPRESS MY GRATITUDE --
I THINK WE HAVE A REALLY STRONG
AND THE MISTER CHAIRMAN YOU WERE
INSTRUMENTAL PART --
IN MAKING THAT HAPPEN SO THANK
YOU.
SCOTT SO I COLLEAGUES I KNOW
THIS BILL HAS BEEN BEFORE YOU
BEFORE I S. B. --
EIGHT TWENTY TWO WILL ENACT A
STRONG NET NEUTRALITY
PROTECTIONS IN CALIFORNIA OUGHT
TO ENSURE THAT RESIDENTS OF
CALIFORNIA --
THAT WE ALL GET TO THE SITE FOR
OURSELVES WHERE WE GO ON THE
INTERNET AS OPPOSED TO HAVING
INTERNET SERVICE PROVIDERS TELL
US WHERE WERE ALLOWED TO GO.
AND WHERE RELY NOT ALLOWED TO GO.
WITHOUT NET NEUTRALITY
PROTECTIONS THERE IS NOTHING
STOP AN INTERNET SERVICE
PROVIDER FROM SAYING YOU KNOW
WHAT THE WALLSTREET JOURNAL OR
THE NEW YORK TIMES OR THE LA
TIMES.
DIDN'T PAY US ENOUGH MONEY.
AND SO THEREFORE WE'RE GONNA
BLOCK THOSE WEBSITES OR MAKE IT
SO SLOW THAT IT'S IMPOSSIBLE
OUGHT TO ACCESS.
OUR OR WILL GET TO THE SIDE THAT
THIS --
SHOPPING SITE I DIDN'T PAY
ENOUGH THIS ONE PAID MORE SERENA
BLOCK THIS WONDER SLOW THIS ONE
DOWN AND YOU GOT TO GO TO THE
OTHER.
ONE WHERE THIS VIDEO STREAMING
SITE THAT IMPASSE ENOUGH OF SO
WE'RE GONNA LET YOU GO HERE BUT
MAKE IT IMPOSSIBLE FOR YOU TO GO
THERE.
ARE THE INTERNET NEEDS TO BE
FREE AND OPEN WHERE WE AS
INDIVIDUALS CUT TO THE SIDE
WHERE WE GO.
ARE WHERE THE NEXT --
AMAZON OR GOOGLE THAT'S THREE
PEOPLE IN SOMEONE'S GARAGE RIGHT
NOW -- GET
TO ACCESS CUSTOMERS WITHOUT
HAVING TO PAY A FEE THAT THEY
CAN'T AFFORD TO PAY.
WITHOUT GETTING ZERO RATED OUT
OF EXISTENCE. TEN YOU ARE
CALIFORNIA'S ROLE AS THE
INTERNATIONAL CAPITAL OF
INNOVATION.
LOT THIS BILL --
TRACKS THE PROTECTIONS OF THE
TWENTY FIFTEEN OBAMA ORDER I
KNOW THERE'S BEEN A LOT OF
INFORMATION PUT OUT --
TO THE CONTRARY AND I
RESPECTFULLY DISAGREE --
WE WORKED EXTREMELY HARD --
IT KNOWING THAT BUT WITH THE
TRANSITION OF ADMINISTRATIONS
OUT WE SAW THE SLOW MOVING TRAIN
WRECK OVER THE COURSE OF LAST
YEAR -- THAT
THE FCC OF WAS PLANNING --
TO ELIMINATE.
ALL FEDERAL NET NEUTRALITY
PROTECTIONS --
AND SO WE WORKED VERY
METHODICALLY WITH FORMER FCCFCC
OUR PERSONNEL WITH ACADEMICS
WITH MEMBERS OF THE BUSINESS
COMMUNITY WITH ADVOCATES OUGHT
TO TAKE WHAT WAS A VERY LENGTHY
THREE HUNDRED PAGE.
FEDERAL ORDER AND REALLY
CONSTRUCTED AS A STATE BILL OF
COURSE ANY CUT STATE LAW IS NOT
GOING THAT LOOK EXACTLY THE SAME
AS AN FCC.
ORDER FCC IS A UTILITY STYLE
REGULATOR THAT'S NOT HOW WE'RE
DOING HERE.
OF BUT WE WORKED HARD TO TRACK
THOSE OPERA TOXINS.
OUGHT THIS AYE AYE IT'S
IMPORTANT FOR CALIFORNIA. TO
TAKE A STAND HERE FOR OUR
RESIDENTS OFF FOR OUR BUSINESSES
WE HAVE GARNERED STRONG AND
BROAD --
SUPPORT OFFER THIS INCLUDING --
PRESIDENT OBAMA'S FCC CHAIRMAN
TOM WHEELER WHO WROTE THE TWENTY
FIFTEEN ORDER HE'S REPEATEDLY.
EMPHATICALLY ENDORSED THE SPELL.
I IN ADDITION --
OUR HEALTH DEMOCRATIC LEADER
NANCY PELOSI SENATOR CHUCK
SCHUMER --
KAMEL HARRIS OUR ATTORNEY
GENERAL HAVEA BRACERO WHO HAS
WORKED VERY CLOSELY WITH US ON
CRAFT IN THE BILL.
ON A BROAD LABOR COALITION LED
BY THE CALIFORNIA LABOR
FEDERATION AND A SIGNIFICANT
LIST OF ADVOCACY ORGANIZATIONS
INCLUDING THE WESTERN CENTER ON
LAW AND POVERTY.
THAT'S JOHN COLOR CHANGED ACLU.
OF THE CALIFORNIA DEMOCRATIC
PARTY THE CAN CALIFORNIA
CONSUMER FEDERATION.
AND ELECTRONIC FRONTIER
FOUNDATION AND THEN A FEW WEEKS
AGO WE RECEIVED A LETTER FROM A
BROAD COALITION OF MIDSIZE
TECHNOLOGY COMPANIES NOT.
THE BIG ONES WHO CAN AFFORD TO
PAY WHATEVER IS DEMANDED OF THEM.
THAT MIDSIZE COMPANIES WHO ARE
TELLING US THAT WITHOUT NET
NEUTRALITY PROTECTIONS THEY WILL
BE ON THEIR MIND AND INNOVATION
AND COMPETITION WILL BE ON THE
MINDS.
OF SO COLLEAGUES I RESPECTFULLY
ASK OF FOR YOUR AYE VOTE I'M
WITH ME TODAY ARE A THREE
WITNESSES ON PROFESSOR SCOTT
JORDAN --
FROM UC IRVINE WHO IS THE FORMER
CHIEF TECHNOLOGY OFFICER AT THE
FCC 420-142-2016 WHICH IS ONE OF
TWENTY FIFTEEN ORDER OF COURSE
WAS PUBLISHED --
PROFESSOR BARBER BANSHEE BACK
OFTEN STANFORD LAW SCHOOL WHO IS
THE DIRECTOR OF STANFORD CENTER
FOR INTERNET AND SOCIETY YOU'VE
HEARD FROM HER.
OUT BEFORE AND THEN MITCH
STEIGER FROM THE CALIFORNIA
LABOR FEDERATION [inaudible]
OFFICER GEORGE.
NOW MISTER CHAIR AND MEMBERS SO
MANY SCOTT JORDAN I SERVED TO US
THAT HE CHIEF TECHNOLOGIST FROM.
TWENTY FOURTEEN TO TWENTY
SIXTEEN AS THE FCC'S MOST SENIOR
TECHNOLOGIST.
I HELPED FORMULATE AND WRITE THE
OPEN INTERNET ORDER THAT WE'RE
TALKING ABOUT AS WELL AS THE
FCC'S REVIEW OF ZERO RATING THAT
WE DID THE PREVIOUS THE NEXT
YEAR.
AND AS WELL AS THE FCC'S VARIOUS
ENDEAVORS OF OVERSIGHT OVER IN A
CONNECTION.
AND SO I WANT TO TALK TODAY TO
YOU BRIEFLY ABOUT THE PARALLEL
BETWEEN SBA TWENTY TO MIRRORING
THE TWENTY FIFTEEN ORDER
[inaudible]
SO THE FCC ORDER AS IT'S BEEN
DISCUSSED SAID NO BLOCKING YOU
SHOULD BE ABLE TO GO WHEREVER
YOU WANT ON THE INTERNET.
NO APPLICATION SPECIFIC
THROTTLING YOU SHOULD BE ABLE TO
USE THE UPS OF YOUR CHOICE.
NO THIRD PARTY P. PRIVATIZATION
YOU SHOULD DETERMINE YOUR OWN
PRIORITY.
TRANSPARENCY YOU SHOULD
UNDERSTAND WHAT YOU'RE BUYING
THE PERFORMANCE OF WHAT YOU'RE
GETTING.
AND YOU KNOW ONE REASONABLE
INTERFERENCE OR DISADVANTAGE AND
I'M GONNA FOCUS PARTICULARLY ON
THAT LATTER.
ONE YOU'VE HEARD A LOT OF CLAIMS
ABOUT ZERO RATING.
SO I WANT TO SET THE RECORD
STRAIGHT.
THE FCC SAID IN THE ORDER.
THAT WE WILL EXAMINE ZERO RATING
POLICIES UNDER THIS NO
UNREASONABLE DISADVANTAGE
STANDARD.
AND THE FOLLOWING YEAR WE WENT
THROUGH AND CONDUCTED A POLICY
ANALYSIS.
AND WE LOOKED AT VARIOUS KINDS
OF ZERO RATING POLICIES.
SO WHAT WE HAD SAID WAS THAT
ZERO RATING POLICIES THAT LOOK
LIKE FREE NIGHTS OR WEEKENDS AT
YOUR MEMBER FROM ALL PHONE
PLANTS.
THERE IS NO HARM IT TO CONSUMER
BENEFIT WOULD BE ALLOWED.
SP THE TWENTY TWO DOES EXACTLY
THE SAME THING.
THE FCC LOOKED AT PLANTS WHERE
VIDEO WOULD BE ZERO RATED AND OF
ALL THAT HE OWES YOUR RATING NOT
JUST PARTICULAR VIDEO.
THE FCC THAT'S A CONSUMER
BENEFIT AND WOULD NOT BE
PROHIBITED SBA TWENTY TWO SAYS
THE SAME EXACT THING.
BUT THEN THE FCC FLAG TO
PARTICULAR CASE.
WHERE ARE THE VIDEO OF THE I SP
ITSELF IS ZERO RATED BUT OTHER
VIDEO IS NOT?
AND THE FCC SAID THAT'S EXACTLY
WHAT.
THE RULE AGAINST.
UNREASONABLE DISADVANTAGES ABOUT.
AND SAID THAT THAT WOULD VIOLATE
THAT RULE SP TWENTY TWO DOES
EXACTLY THE SAME THING.
ON INTERCONNECTION AGAIN YOU'VE
HEARD A LOT ABOUT THIS.
BUT EXPLICITLY SAY THE FCC ORDER
DID COVER INTERCONNECTION.
WHAT IT SAID WAS THAT WHEN YOU
BY INTERNET SERVICE FROM YOUR
ISP THEY PROMISE TO GET YOU
WHEREVER YOU WANT TO GO ON THE
INTERNET AND TO BRING THOSE
WEBPAGES CONTENT BACK?
TO THE PART OF THAT TRANSPORT
THAT'S ON THEIR NETWORK IS WERE
THE NO BLOCKING OR THROTTLING
RULES APPLY.
BUT THE PROMISE GOES BEYOND THAT
IT GOES TO WHEREVER YOU WANT TO
GO ON THE INTERNET.
AND INTERCONNECTION AGREEMENTS A
CRUCIAL PART OF THAT.
SO THE FCC SAID.
IF INTERCONNECTION AGREEMENTS
ARE BEING USED TO BE VERY AID.
THE MAIN RULES LIKE NO BLOCKING
OR THROTTLING.
THAT THAT WOULD ALSO BE
PROHIBITED UNDER THE ORDER.
AND THE FCC HAS FOLLOWED UP OVER
THE COURSE OF THE REST OF THE
NEXT YEAR TO BEFORE THE CHANGE
AND THE POWERS THAT BE.
IN ORDER TO FOLLOW THAT.
SO I WOULD ENCOURAGE YOU. TO IN
OUR QUESTIONS BE HAPPY TO TAKE.
I'M HAPPY TO FOLLOW UP ON THE
PARALLELS BETWEEN THESE.
TO I JUST WANT TO CLOSE BY
NOTING THAT THIS IS THE HIGHEST
PROFILE TELECOM INTERNET ISSUE
THAT EVER CAME BEFORE THE FCC.
THERE WERE MORE THAN TWENTY
MILLION COMMENTS FILED BY THE
PUBLIC INCLUDING MORE THAN TWO
MILLION FROM CALIFORNIA.
IT'S UNHEARD OF FOR THAT MANY
PEOPLE TO GO OUT OF THEIR WAY
OUT FILE COMMENTS WITH THE
FEDERAL AGENCY ON AN ISSUE LIKE
THAT.
AND IT'S BIPARTISAN MORE THAN
80% SUPPORT BOTH AMONGST
DEMOCRATS AND REPUBLICANS.
SO I LOOK FORWARD TO YOUR
QUESTION.
I CAN'T IT MISTER CHAIRMAN
FORGET THE NEXT WITNESS I DIDN'T
LIKE ONE THING --
WE HAVE DISTRIBUTED TO THE
COMMITTEE --
A ARE A US VERY SURGICAL
AMENDMENT DELETING THE LAST THE
SENTENCE OF THE BILL OF WHICH IS
THE CONTINGENT ENACTMENTS.
A LANGUAGE OF THE AMENDMENT DOES
NOT I ANYWAY CHANGE I DON'T
BELIEVE I HAVE IN THE* HER
EYES AND WOOD SOME COMMITTEE
MEMBERS MAY NOT.
IT WITH DOG YOU KNOW YOU KNOW I
SPOKE ABOUT IT BUT LATELY
YESTERDAY BUT I DON'T.
IT WAS GIVEN THE SERGEANTS
[inaudible]
TO WHAT.
IT WILL GO THROUGH THEM RIGHT
NOW.
YOU MAY WANT EXPLAINED THAT
[inaudible]
TO YES [inaudible]
I OKAY AWESOME MISTER CHAIRMAN
TO MEMBERS THE THE AMENDMENT OF
THE LEADS SENT BUT ONLY THE LAST
SENTENCE OF THE OF THE ENTIRE
BILL NO OTHER CHANGES.
ARE AND THAT IS THE LANGUAGE
THAT MAKES --
ENACTMENT OF SP TWENTY TWO
CONTINGENT ON THE ENACTMENT OF
US BEFORE SIXTEEN SO IT WOULD
AYE IT BOTH BOTH STILL MOVE
FORWARD.
ON THE JOINT AUTHORED BOTH SIDES
HOPE THEY DO --
BUT IT WOULD ELIMINATE THAT ARE
CONSIDERED CONTINGENT ENACTMENTS
ABOUT LANGUAGE --
IT'S ABOUT SO AND AGAIN IT
DOESN'T IN ANY WAY CHANGE THE
SUBSTANCE OF THE BILL SIMPLY
BELIEVING THE LAST SENTENCE OF
THOUGHTS BEEN OUR HISTORY.
MISTER CHAIRMAN OF THE BILL AS
AMENDED.
ARE YOU WOULD NEED A SECOND A
PROCEED. ONE NOT GOING TO
CONTINUE WITH ADDITIONAL
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN.
CHAIRMAN SANTIAGO MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE THANK YOU FOR INVITING
ME TO TESTIFY TODAY.
MY NAME A SPOT ROUGH AND SHE VIC
I'M A PROFESSOR OF LAW AT
STANFORD LAW SCHOOL AND THE
DIRECTOR OF THE CENTER FOR INTO
ITS IN SOCIETY THE I'M HERE TO I
HAVE A PHD IN COMPUTER SCIENCE
AND A LAW DEGREE.
I'M HERE TODAY AS AN INDEPENDENT
ACADEMIC WHO HAS WORKED ON NET
NEUTRALITY FOR SEVENTEEN YEARS.
THE F. C. C.'S TWENTY TEN AND
TWENTY FIFTEEN OPEN INTERNET
RULES RELIED HEAVILY ON MY WORK.
AS DID THE INDIAN AND CANADIAN
RULES ON ZERO RATING AND THE
EUROPEAN UNION NET NEUTRALITY
GUIDELINES.
I'LL LEAVE MY TESTIMONY AT THE
OUT AND I'D BE HAPPY TO ANSWER
ANY QUESTIONS YOU MIGHT HAVE.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS
MITCH STEIGER WITH THE
CALIFORNIA LABOR FEDERATION ALSO
IN STRONG SUPPORT OF THE BILL --
MAINLY BECAUSE OF THE DIRECT
CONNECTION BETWEEN NET
NEUTRALITY AND WORKERS RIGHTS
ORGANIZE WHICH ESSENTIALLY IS
JUST A WORKERS RIGHT TO
COMMUNICATE OUR ABILITY.
TO COME TOGETHER TLK ABOUT
WAGES BENEFITS WORKING
THAT.
SO AS LONG AS THERE'S BEEN A
LABOR MOVEMENT HAS BEEN
SOMETHING THAT'S VERY CENTRAL TO
EVERYTHING THAT WE DO AND THE
SAD REALITY IS THAT SOMETHING
THAT EMPLOYERS HAVE ALWAYS
FOUGHT.
ARM WHEN WE MET IN PERSON IT WAS
ARMED MILITIAS TO BREAK IT UP
WHEN WE STARTED COMMUNICATING BY
PHONE -- WE
NEED AT THE EXCELSIOR DECISION
TO CONFIRM OUR ABILITY TO GET A
LIST OF WORKERS AND THEIR PHONE
NUMBER SO THAT WE CAN CONTACT
THEM.
AND FAST FOR TO TWENTY EIGHTEEN
DO A LOT OF THIS CAN EDUCATION
ONLINE --
THAT DRIVE TO FIGHTER BILLION
COMMUNICATE CONTINUES RIGHT NOW
THERE'S AN APP CALLED WORK IT
THAT A LOT OF WALMART EMPLOYEES
USE AND TOM.
WALMARTS AS A LOT OF TIME AND
MONEY TRYING TO KEEP WORKERS
FROM DOWNLOADING IT --
AS WE SPEAK THE NLRB IS MOVING
TO ALLOW EMPLOYERS TO PROHIBIT
WORKERS FROM COMMUNICATING OVER
EMAIL --
DURING OVER WORK EMAIL DURING
NON WORK HOURS AND SO THIS IT'S
SOMETHING THAT IS ALWAYS AN
ISSUE AND YOU KNOW WILL BE AN
ISSUE AS LONG AS THERE'S A LABOR
MOVEMENT AND OVER ARCHING ALL OF
THIS NOW IS NET NEUTRALITY WHICH
IS SOMETHING THAT IS SO CUTE WAS
BECAUSE SO.
MUCH OF THIS ORGANIZING HAPPENS
ONLINE NOWADAYS AND WITHOUT
SENATE BILL.
EIGHT TWENTY TWO IT'S PRETTY
SCARY TO THINK ABOUT WHAT THAT
WORLD COULD LOOK LIKE ARM
WITHOUT THOSE PROTECTIONS ARE
ESPECIALLY FOR WORKERS IN THE
TELECOMMUNICATIONS INDUSTRY.
WHERE IT WOULD BE EXCEPTIONALLY
EASY FOR AN EMPLOYER TO SLOW
DOWN OR BLOCK THE ABILITY TO
COMMUNICATE ONLINE ALL TOGETHER?
AND THAT'S SOMETHING THAT'S
ACTUALLY HAPPENED A WIN TELESAT
WORKERS THAT WERE ORGANIZING.
THEY DIRECTLY BLOCKED WORKERS
ACCESS TO WEBSITE THAT THEY WERE
USING AND THAT'S THE KIND OF
THING THAT WE CAN PROBABLY
EXPECT MORE OF IF WE KEEP GOING
INTO A WORLD WITHOUT NET
NEUTRALITY.
AND WHEN YOU PILE THAT ON TO ALL
THE OTHER ATTACKS THAT WERE
FACING.
THE FEDERAL LEVEL FROM THE NLRB
FROM THIS THE SUPREME COURT --
STATE REGULATORY BARS ARE IN A
FEDERAL REGULATORY BODIES AND A
LOT OF OTHER AREAS OR BILLION
COMMUNICATE OVER FAIR IN A FREE
AND OPEN INTERNET IS REALLY KIND
OF OUR ONLY HOPE FOR SURVIVAL
AND SO IT'S SOMETHING THAT'S
INCREDIBLY IMPORTANT TO US AND
WE URGE YOUR SUPPORT FOR THE YOU.
STILL HAVE ABOUT THREE MINUTES
IF YOU WANT TO USE IT WE WERE
RECOMMENDING TO JUST SIMPLY DO A
LOT OF FOR NEXT TIME.
WERE AND I'M NOT RECOMMENDING
YOU DO BUT NONE THE LESS YOU
HAVE IT WERE HOT WHO WERE RIGHT
NOT FAIR TO EVERYBODY MISTER JOE
HAPPY TO MOVE THE HEARING.
FOR ANY ADDITIONAL WITNESSES IN
SUPPORT AGAIN WE WANT RYAN
REMIND YOU IT'S ONLY NAME
ORGANIZE --
AFFILIATION [inaudible]
AND POSITION.
I HAD CRISTINA CAHILL WITH
INDIVISIBLE SACRAMENTO IN STRONG
SUPPORT OF THE BILL.
HI MY NAME IS JENNIFER TANNER I
REPRESENT INDIVISIBLE CALIFORNIA
STATE STRONG TWENTY THOUSAND
THEM TWO HUNDRED THOUSAND
MEMBERS.
AND STRONG SUPPORT OF SB A TWO
TO MY NAME IS ALAN CHAPMAN A
REPRESENT INDIVISIBLE SACRAMENTO
WE STAND IN STRONG SUPPORT OF
THIS BILL.
I AND THE REST EXECUTIVE
DIRECTOR OF CALPERS THE
CALIFORNIA PUBLIC INTEREST
RESEARCH GROUP IN SUPPORT.
KAREN LANG ON HAVE A MARYLAND IN
BRITAIN THE CITY COUNTY SAN
FRANCISCO IN SUPPORT. FOR LESS
OF A CAR ON BEHALF OF THE
ELECTRONIC FRONTIER FOUNDATION
AND STRONG SUPPORTER ALSO --
AND SPEAK ABOUT MY COLLEAGUES AT
NEW MEDIA RIGHTS FIGHT FOR THE
FUTURE CONSUMERS UNION GREEN
LINE INSTITUTE.
OAKLAND PRIVACY CREDO MOBILE A
COLOR CHANGE ALL IN STRONG
SUPPORT.
TRAVELING CALIFORNIA THE MONEY
CAMPAIGN IN STRONG SUPPORT.
RALPH FINLEY SILICON VALLEY --
CALIFORNIA CLEAN MONEY VOLUNTEER
PLEASE.
GARY APPEL FROM MILL VALLEY
CLEAN MONEY FUND THE NOVELLA
COMMUNITY ACTION NETWORK STRONG
SUPPORT PLEASE.
SHERRI FITZGERALD VALLEJO
CALIFORNIA MEMBER OF CALIFORNIA
CLEAN MONEY CAMPAIGN.
AND I'M URGING STRONG SUPPORT
FOR EIGHT TWENTY TWO IT IS THE
ASSESSMENT ESSENCE UP JUST NAME
OBLIGATION AND POSITION PLEASE
THANK YOU.
CALVET QUICK BAY AREA STERN ACT
A STRONG SUPPORT PIC.
EVAN MINTON VOICES FOR PROGRESS
IN STRONG SUPPORT ALSO THE
CALIFORNIA DEMOCRATIC PARTY IN
STRONG SUPPORT.
DON CURRYING MENLO PARK STRONG
SUPPORT.
KAREN WILSON VALLEJO ICED HOPE
YOU SUPPORT [inaudible]
VERY MUCH.
CAN MCPHERSON ARE I URGE STRONG
SUPPORT IN THIS WERE --
STUDENTS TO USE RESEARCH IN THE
FUTURE THANK YOU.
MATT BROUGHT ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA TEAMSTERS IN SUPPORT
KIA.
ALLEN MARLIN FROM ALAMEDA STRONG
SUPPORT NET NEUTRALITY.
TELLING US PEOPLE PLEASANT HILL
CALIFORNIA CLEAN MONEY AND MONEY
OUT PEOPLE AND STRONG SUPPORT.
HI KAREN BACK FROM DANVILLE.
WE HOPE YOU SUPPORT IT.
GRAHAM HERE WE WANT CREEK HOPE
YOU SUPPORT IT.
S. B. WHAT REMINDED THAT
YESTERDAY'S ARTICLE DOES THAT
NAME AFFILIATION POSITIONALLY
PLEASE.
THAT'S WHEN OAKLAND CALIFORNIA
STRONG SUPPORT.
RAY CHECK A TEENY CONCORD
CALIFORNIA STRONG SUPPORT.
JEAN JACKET TEENY CITIZEN OF
CONCORD I URGE YOUR SUPPORT.
NICARAGUA BEHALF OF THE SAN
FRANCISCO UNIFIED SCHOOL
DISTRICT THE SANTA CLARA COUNTY
OFFICE OF EDUCATION AND ALSO ON
BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
EDUCATIONAL TECHNOLOGY
PROFESSIONALS ASSOCIATION ALL IN
SUPPORT.
HI TERRY GUESS ON BEHALF OF THE
OFFICER REPAIR ADVOCATES IN
STRONG SUPPORT.
MORNING CARB ALTERNATIVE
STRATEGY GROUP ON BEHALF OF THE
UTILITY REFORM NETWORK AS WELL
AS THE COMMUNICATION WORKERS OF
AMERICA DISTRICT NINE ENDS IN
SUPPORT.
CHRIS HAMILTON ONE OF THE TWO
MILLION MENTIONED IN THE
TESTIMONY FROM BERKELEY FROM THE
ALBENA POLITICAL CAUCUS
[inaudible]
VOTE YES.
GLORIA PURCELL CALIFORNIA CLEAN
MONEY A CAMPAIGN AND GREEN PARTY
PLEASE SUPPORT.
GLENDA HELLMAN SACRAMENTO
RESIDENT AND MEMBER OF ORGANIZED
WHEN LEGISLATOR STRONGLY SUPPORT.
WHO IS MALE THERE SACRAMENTO
CLEAN MONEY ACLU IN SUPPORT?
AND I BUCK ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF
REALTORS IN SUPPORT.
KATHLEEN MILLER FROM LINCOLN
CALIFORNIA THAT CITIZEN AND I
URGE YOUR ETHICAL VOTE IN
SUPPORT OF THESE BILLS.
AMONG THIS YEAR FROM DAVIS CLEAN
MONEY CAMPAIGN AND THEY SEE ALL
YOU IN SUPPORT.
ROBERT COOPER FROM THE CLEAN
RUNNING CAMPAIGN OF MASS AND THE
GREEN PARTY OF SUPPORT IN
SACRAMENTO.
NANCY ENOUGH IN PALO ALTO IN
SUPPORT.
SUSIE ARNETT FROM STOCKTON --
CALIFORNIA CLEAN MONEY AND
SOMEONE CAME PEACE AND JUSTICE
URGES STRONG SUPPORT.
BILL HILTON CALIFORNIA CLEAN
MONEY CAMPAIGN.
AND SANTA CLARA COUNTY VOTER.
PLEASE SUPPORT THIS BILL.
LARRY BATHGATE FROM MILL VALLEY
CALIFORNIA AND I URGE YOUR
STRONG SUPPORT OF THIS BILL
THANK YOU.
CHRISTOPHER LISTS FROM SANDRA
FELT PLEASE SUPPORT.
PLAYING LOS ALTOS HILLS PLEASE
SUPPORT.
MAGGIE WHITE WITH CAL STATE
STUDENT ASSOCIATION STRONG
SUPPORT BINKY ON POWER RANDALL
CALIFORNIA CLEAN MONEY CAMPAIGN
SAN FRANCISCO PLEASE SUPPORT.
MARY RYAN FROM SAN FRANCISCO
STRONG SUPPORTER OF THE SPILL.
KILEY CONFIGURE SHE CALLISON
FRANCISCO ACT ON BEHALF OF YOUR
CONSTITUENTS AND VOTE IN FAVOR
OF THIS BILL.
SARAH CASPI SACRAMENTO STRONG
SUPPORT.
DAVID BACHELOR OF SACRAMENTO ON
BEHALF OF THE WORKING POOR AYE
PLEASE PASS THIS BILL.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN WAS MY
CONSUMERS ON BEHALF OF THE QUE
O. GREAT WRITERS GUILD OF
CALIFORNIA OF A MY GOSH.
WRITERS GUILD OF AMERICA WEST
TEN THOUSAND UNION WRITERS IN
CALIFORNIA AND SUPPORT.
MISTER CHAIRMAN MEMBERS TONY
GONZALEZ ON BEHALF OF EDT
SECURITY SERVICES HERE AND SO --
MICHAEL RIGHT AGAIN ON BEHALF OF
THE BOARD SUPERVISOR SANTA CLARA
COUNTY IN SUPPORT.
WE'RE NAY BAYARDO IS HERE YOU
CALIFORNIANS OR I HAVE NEVER
DONE REPRESENT NEXT AND
CALIFORNIANS SUPPORT.
JAZZY GIRL UCW WESTERN STATES
COUNCIL IN STRONG SUPPORT.
JUST BARTOLO WESTERN CENTER ON
LAW AND POVERTY IN SUPPORT.
ANGELINA AT ASIAN AMERICANS
ADVANCING JUSTICE CALIFORNIANS
CHUNKS PART.
HOW HER SMARTS CAMPUS ORGANIZER
AT CALVARY AT UCSB IN SUPPORT?
AND THE DISNEY CALIFORNIA PUBLIC
INTEREST RESEARCH GROUP
ORGANIZER AND STRONG SUPPORT.
KEVIN BAKER AMERICAN CIVIL
LIBERTIES UNION OF CALIFORNIA
ALSO IN SPORT.
KYLE HOUSE WITH CALPERS TRIMS AT
UCLA IN STRONG SUPPORT.
NICHOLAS RONNIE WITH CALPERS
STUDENTS AT UCLA IN STRONG
SUPPORT.
ADAM BELLING WITH CALPERS
STUDENTS AT UCSD IN STRONG
SUPPORT.
MARIO GUERRERO ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA FACULTY ASSOCIATION
IN STRONG SUPPORT.
RAIN HICKS CALIFORNIA DISABILITY
RIGHTS THINKING STRONG SUPPORT.
MY DEAR GOVIND NORTHERN
CALIFORNIA POOR PEOPLE'S
CAMPAIGN.
THE INTERNET IS THE NEW COMMENTS
PLEASE DON'T BLAME IT ON OF
SILLY ATION A POSITION ONLY
PLEASE.
DOCTOR MANDATE KILL WITH
INDIVISIBLE HE SPAIN IS
INDIVISIBLE CENSUS CHO THE
SEVERAL THOUSAND MEMBERS STRONG
SUPPORT.
MACKLIN SMALL BUSINESS OWNER AND
MEMBER OF THE AMERICAN
SUSTAINABLE BUSINESS COUNCIL IN
STRONG SUPPORT.
A CRAIG DUNKERLEY CALIFORNIA
CLEAN MONEY CAMPAIGN DITTO.
NOW WE HAVE WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION
.
THANK YOU JUST ONE REMIND OF THE
GROUND RULES YOU HAVE TEN
MINUTES ON THE SIDE.
USE IT HOW YOU WANT WE ALL
STATED TO BE FOUND BOTH SIDES
RECOMMENDED TWO MINUTES BUT
CERTAINLY CAN USE ALL TEN
NONETHELESS PLEASE.
MISTER CHAIRMAN MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE OF MY NAME IS BILL
DIVIDE THAT REPRESENT A TNT.
OUR THANK THE COMMITTEE FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY TO TESTIFY TODAY.
OUR LET ME JUST STATE FOR THE
RECORD THAT EIGHTEEN T. SUPPORTS
AN OPEN INTERNET AND ARE AND THE
NET NEUTRALITY PRINCIPLES ARE ON
OUR WEBSITE AND THERE
ENFORCEABLE TODAY BY THE
CALIFORNIA ATTORNEY GENERAL.
AS WELL AS THE FEDERAL AGENCIES
WITH JURISDICTION.
BUT I AM HERE TODAY TO OPPOSE S.
B. A TWENTY TWO SIXTY THREE DAYS
AGO THIS COMMITTEE HEARD THAT
BILL.
AND ADOPTED AMENDMENTS TO
REFLECT THE ACTUAL TWO THOUSAND
FIFTEEN OBAMA ORDER.
AS YOUR COMMITTEE ANALYSIS
STATED ON PAGE NINE QUOTE THIS
BILL SEEKS TO INCLUDE ADDITIONAL
PROHIBITIONS.
THAT WERE NOT PRESCRIBED IN THE
FINAL FCC RULES.
TODAY AS BE EIGHT TWENTY TWO IS
BEFORE YOU AGAIN.
YES BE A TWENTY TO RESTORES
FLAWED LANGUAGE YOU REJECTED
JUST TWO MONTHS AGO. TWO ISSUES
I'D LIKE TO ADDRESS THE FIRST
BEING ZERO RATING.
A TWENTY TWO WOULD WHAT AND
POPULAR DRIVE CONSUMER DRIVEN
ZERO READING PROGRAMS --
WE HAVE PRODUCED A STUDY.
AND FOUND THAT THESE PROGRAMS
ARE ENJOYED BY THREE POINT SIX
MILLION CALIFORNIANS FOR SAVING
AS MUCH AS THIRTY DOLLARS A
MONTH USING ZERO READING
PROGRAMS.
THE STUDY FOUND THE LOST OF
THESE TYPES OF PROGRAMS WOULD
DISPROPORTIONATELY IMPACT
MINORITIES LOW INCOME CONSUMERS.
THE TWO THOUSAND FIFTEEN FCC
ORDER DID NOT BAN ZERO RATING
PROGRAMS.
IN TWO THOUSAND SIXTEEN IN AN
INTERVIEW WITH FCC CHAIRMAN TOM
WHEELER I QUOTE.
WE WERE QUITE SPECIFIC IN THE
OPEN INTERNET ORDER SAYING WE
WEREN'T GOING TO ADDRESS ZERO
RATING BECAUSE WE COULD ARGUE IT
BOTH WAYS AND OF QUOTE.
AND JUST LAST YEAR BY THE WAY I
WAS BROUGHT UP HERE EARLIER THE
EUROPEAN UNION.
AS WELL AS ONE OF THE LAST
HEARINGS JUST LAST YEAR THE U. A
EUROPEAN UNION CONCLUDED QUOTE
THERE APPEARS TO BE LITTLE
REASON TO BELIEVE.
THAT ZERO RATING.
GIVES YOU A RISE TO COMPETITIVE
CONCERNS UNQUOTE.
THE SECOND BIG ISSUE IN THIS
BILL THAT WE OBJECT TO IS
INTERCONNECTION.
THE FCC ORDER DID NOT APPLY NET
NEUTRALITY RULES TO
INTERCONNECTION PAGE TEN
PARAGRAPH THIRTY OF THE FCC
ORDER QUOTE THIS ORDER DOES NOT
APPLY OPEN INTERNET RULES TO
INNER CONNECTION UNQUOTE.
ON PAGE NINETY TWO PARAGRAPH TWO
OH TO WE CONCLUDE IT WOULD BE
PREMATURE. TO ADOPT PRESCRIPTIVE
RULES TO ADDRESS ANY PROBLEMS
THAT EVER RISEN OR MAY ARISE AND
OF QUOTE.
THE INDUSTRY HAS COMPLIED WITH
THE OBAMA RULES THAT WERE
ADOPTED IN TWO THOUSAND FIFTEEN
AND CONTINUED IN PLACE THROUGH
THE BEGINNING OF TWO THOUSAND
AND EIGHTEEN THE INDUSTRY DID
NOT CHANGE INTERCONNECTION
AGREEMENTS.
DURING THAT TIME. TO SUGGEST
THAT THE OBAMA RULES PROHIBITED
CHARGING FOR INTERCONNECTION
WITH AGE PROVIDERS IS NOT TRUE.
S. B. A TWENTY TWO IS A RADICAL
DEPARTURE FROM THE HISTORICALLY
SUCCESSFUL INTERNET POLICY
THAT'S BEEN IN PLACE.
SINCE THE CLINTON ADMINISTRATION
ADOPTED LIKE TOUCH REGULATION IN.
NINETEEN NINETY SIX LET ME
CONCLUDE BY SUGGESTING THIS WE
BELIEVE THIS BILL IS ANTI
COMPETITIVE.
AND AND I CONSUMER AND IS SURELY
GOING TO BE CHALLENGED UNDER
FEDERAL PREEMPTION.
IT WILL DRIVE UP YOUR
CONSTITUENTS BILLS FOR INTERNET
SERVICE.
IT WILL PROHIBIT POPULAR FREE
DATA PROGRAMS A CONSUMERS ENJOY
OVER THEIR WIRELESS PROGRAMS.
AND WE BELIEVE IT'LL INCREASE
LITIGATION COSTS.
AND THE QUESTION I HOPE THE
COMMITTEE WILL ASK FOR WHAT
BENEFIT.
S. B. EIGHT TWENTY TWO IS BUILT
UPON SPECULATION THAT SOMEBODY.
SOMEWHERE SOMETIME IN THE FUTURE
MIGHT VOLATILE VIOLATE NET
NEUTRALITY PRINCIPLES.
TODAY THE NET NEUTRALITY
PRINCIPLES ARE ENFORCEABLE BY
THE CALIFORNIA ATTORNEY GENERAL.
THE FEDERAL TRADE COMMISSION AND
THE FEDERAL COMMUNICATIONS.
WE BELIEVE THIS BILL WILL CREATE
A REGULATORY [inaudible]
A COMPLIANCE AND A LITIGATION
ENVIRONMENT THAT WILL HARM
CALIFORNIA CONSUMERS AND
ACTUALLY WEAKEN CALIFORNIA'S
LEADERSHIP.
IN TECHNOLOGICAL INNOVATION.
THANK YOU FOR THE OPPORTUNITY TO
SPEAK TODAY.
MISTER CHAIRMAN AND MEMBERS
CAROLINE MCINTYRE ON BEHALF OF
THE CALIFORNIA CABLE AND
TELECOMMUNICATIONS ASSOCIATION.
I TOO WOULD LIKE TO START BY
SAYING THE MEMBERS OF THE
CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION AND ALSO
SUPPORT AND OPEN INTERNET AND WE
ADHERE TO THE PRINCIPLES OF NET
NEUTRALITY.
THAT HAVE BEEN DESCRIBED AS THE
BRIGHT LINE PRINCIPLES.
BUT I WANT TO POINT OUT THAT OUT
WHILE WE ARE HERE IN OPPOSITION
TO THESE ROLES IT IS IN PART
BECAUSE WE BELIEVE THE STATE IS
STEPPING BEYOND.
THEIR LEGAL JURISDICTION AND
IMPOSING ANY REQUIREMENTS IN
THAT SPACE.
WE BELIEVE FIRST OF ALL THAT HAD
THE STATE IS PREEMPTED OF THE
INTERNET IS IN FACT I'M IN
INTERSTATE SERVICE AND IS
SUBJECT TO THE RULES OF
INTERSTATE COMMERCE.
BOTH THE FCC UNDER PRESIDENT
OBAMA AND THE CURRENT FCC HAVE
ALSO A PARTICULARLY THAT THEIR
INTENT TO PREEMPT THE STATES IN
THIS SPACE.
AND WHILE SAID WHILE AT CHAIRMAN
WIENER IS OFTEN CITED AS THE AB
PRINCIPLE SUPPORTER OF THIS
LEGISLATION NOTING THAT STATE
LEGISLATION IS APPROPRIATE.
I'D LIKE TO QUOTE FROM AB THE
FROM CHAIRMAN LEGAL AIR AS
RECENTLY AS THIS MONTH WHERE HE
WROTE.
IN A PAPER TITLED TIME TO FIX IT
DEVELOPING RULES FOR THE
INTERNET CAPITALISM.
AUGUST TWENTY EIGHTEEN AND A
NATION IN WHICH THE INTERNET IS
OBLIVIOUS TO STATE BOUNDARIES A
LACK OF UNIFORMITY BETWEEN
STATES CAN IMPOSE SIGNIFICANT.
BE AT BURDENS AND UNCERTAINTIES
I'M COMPANIES THAT IS OUR
CONCERN HERE TODAY ABOUT HAVING
STATE BY STATE LEGISLATION.
WE BELIEVE THAT THIS WILL RESULT
IN THE AYE NOT ONLY SIGNIFICANT
OPERATIONAL BURDENS THAT WILL
POTENTIALLY UPSET THE OPERATION
OF THE INTERNET.
BUT INSIGNIFICANT LEGAL
CHALLENGES I WOULD LIKE TO SPEAK
DIRECTLY TO SOME OF THE CLAIMS
OF THE THAT THE PROPONENTS HAVE
MADE WITH REGARDS TO
INTERCONNECTION.
I'M THERE ARE CLAIMS THAT
INTERCONNECTION IS NOT BEING
PROHIBIT.
BUT THE LANGUAGE OF THE BILL WAS
SPECIFIC TO PROHIBITING MONETARY
OR OTHER CONSIDERATION FOR
INTERCONNECTION AGREEMENTS.
THAT IN FACT GOES BEYOND ITS
POINTED OUT BY MISTER DEVINE
GOES BEYOND THE TWENTY FIFTEEN
ORDER.
BUT I WOULD ADD TO THAT THAT ICE
PIECE OF MADE BILLIONS OF
DOLLARS IN INVESTMENTS WITH THE
UNDERSTANDING.
THAT THE COST CAN BE RECOUPED.
S. B. EIGHT TWENTY TWO WHICH
CHECKED ALL OF THOSE COSTS MANY
THAT HAVE BEEN PAID FOR DECADES
BY INTERCONNECTION PARTNERS. TWO
WHY S. P. CUSTOMERS YOUR
CONSTITUENTS.
THERE'S ALSO BEEN SOME
DISCUSSION ABOUT THE BILL
INCLUDING A SAFE HARBOR.
IF SENATOR WE ARE TRULY WANT IT
TO CREATE A SAFE HARBOR THEN THE
BILL WOULD NOT APPLY TO
INTERCONNECTION AGREEMENTS THAT
HAVE BEEN AND YET IN PLACE FOR
YEARS.
AND DON'T APPLY ON A STATE BY
STATE BASIS.
BASICALLY WE ARE BEING ASKED TO
IMPOSE UP TO WITH ABBOTT TO
COMPLY WITH THE REQUIREMENT HERE
AT THE STATE LEVEL THAT IS GOING
TO UPS THAT CONTRACTS THAT GO
WELL BEYOND THE BORDERS OF
CALIFORNIA. TO THE EXTENT YOU
HAVE ANY RESPECT AT ALL FOR WITH
THAT PART OF THE PROCESS.
SOME CONSIDERATION SHOULD BE
GIVEN TO SOME PRESCRIPTIVE
APPLICATION AS OPPOSED TO
INTERRUPTING EXISTING CONTRACT.
SO I DID I JUST WANT TO BE CLEAR
THATWE DO SUPPORT AN OPEN ENDED
THAT BUT THE PROVISIONS OF SB
EIGHT TO TO GO WELL BEYOND THAT
AND GO BUT WELL BEYOND.
ANYTHING THAT I THINK ANYONE
HERE COULD ENVISION IN TERMS OF
THE OPERATION THE BUSINESS
OPERATION OF THE INTERNET.
AND FOR THOSE REASONS WE OPPOSE
THIS BILL.
MISTER CHAIRMAN MEMBER STEVE
CARLTON HER CTIA THE WIRELESS
THAT I JUST WANT TO REMIND YOU
HAVE THREE MINUTES LEFT AS A
COURTESY TO LET YOU FINISH YOUR
COMMENTS I WILL CUT YOU OFF BUT
JUST TO BE FAIR ON BOTH SIDES
GET.
THANK YOU --
I'D LIKE TO ADDRESS MY COMMENTS
TO THE PROCESS THAT GOT US HERE
TODAY WHICH I THINK IT'S A BIT
MYSTIFYING.
BUT THE NEGATIVE IMAGE THIS WILL
CREATE FOR CALIFORNIA'S
REPUTATION AS A LEADER IN
TECHNOLOGY INNOVATION.
AND THE NEGATIVE IMPACT IT'LL
HAVE ON MUCH NEEDED INVESTMENT
NEXT GENERATION TECHNOLOGIES
LIKE FIVE G..
THIS BILL THESE BILLS WILL BE
HEARING TODAY GO WELL BEYOND THE
FCC'S TWENTY FIFTEEN ORDER.
IT WAS IT WAS SAID THAT THIS IS
THIS BILL TRACKS TWENTY FIFTEEN
ORDER.
IT DIDN'T JUST TRACK IT SPEEDS
RIGHT PAST IT.
PROPONENTS OFFER JUSTIFICATIONS
AS TO WHY IT GOES BEYOND THE
TWENTY FIFTEEN ORDER NUMBER
VARIAS THEN REVERT TO SAYING
THAT WEALTHIEST OF THE A BOMB
RULES. TO ASSEMBLY COMMITTEES
INCLUDING THIS ONE OFFERED
AMENDMENTS TO A TWENTY TWO
FAITHFUL TO THE OBAMA RULES.
THEY WERE REJECTED.
AMBER TOLD BUT CAN'T BE THAT
SIMPLE.
AND THEN AGAIN WE'RE REVERTING
TO SAY WHAT THE TO THE OBAMA
RULES.
AT THE SAME OR DIFFERENT CLEARLY
TO STEP.
FOR I'D LIKE TO KNOW HOW MANY OF
YOUR BILLS.
WOULD BE SIX STILL ALIVE IN THE
SENATE IF YOU REJECTED
AMENDMENTS FOR TWO SENATE
COMMITTEES.
THE BUDGET FOLKS HERE DIDN'T GET
WHAT THEY WANTED IN THE TWENTY
FIFTEEN ORDER AND ARE TRYING TO
GET IT HERE IN CALIFORNIA. TO
REGULATORY MODEL THAT INDEED
GOES WELL BEYOND SUPPORTED BY.
A NUMBER OF NEWS OUTLETS AFTER
THE LAST COMMITTEE HEARING
INCLUDING THE CHICO PRESS
ENTERPRISE WHICH SAID I QUOTE.
WINNERS ESPY AB TWENTY TWO GOES
EVEN FURTHER THAN THE NOW
REPEALED FEDERAL RULES.
THE OTHER SUFFERED SIMILAR
AFFIRMATION EIGHT TWENTY TWO IS
NOT THE TWENTY FIFTEEN OBAMA
RULES.
BUT WHAT IS A SAYING BACK
CALIFORNIA THE CRUCIBLE OF
INTERNET AND TELECOMMUNICATIONS
INNOVATION INVESTMENT WHOSE
GROWTH AND BENEFITS HAVE BEEN
PRECISELY BECAUSE OF A LIGHT
TOUCH REGULATORY FEDERAL
REGULATORY MODEL.
WE HAVE BEEN IT CAN NEED TO
CONTINUE TO BE THE LEADER
ENCOURAGING ENCOURAGING
INNOVATION CREATIVITY AND
INVESTMENT.
NOT THE STATE THAT BRAG THAT HAS
THE MOST PRESCRIPTIVE INTERNET
REGULATION AND DAMAGING INTERNET
REGULATION IN THE COUNTRY IF NOT
THE WORLD IS THAT WE WANT TO BE
KNOWN.
FOR I DON'T THINK SO.
PLEASE I DO NOT ONE LET ME KNOW
WE HAD TEMAS BERMAN LET YOU
CONTINUE THANK YOU.
PLEASE TELL A FEAR OF ON REALIZE
TARGETED BASIS FOR LAWS THAT
WILL CURB NOT STIFLED THE NECK
SITE FOR THE NEXT GENERATION OF
DIGITAL INNOVATION.
PLEASE DO NOT LET ALARMIST
SPECULATION LA RHETORIC TO
TRIUMPH OVER REALITY ARGENEAU
VOTE ON AS BEGIN.
TWENTY TWO IF THE COMMITTEE
WOULD INDULGE ME I'D LIKE THAT
LET THE LAST WITNESS AT LEAST
HAVE A MONITOR SOME.
BUSES ANY OBJECTIONS I AS CHAIR
I APPRECIATE THAT I'LL BE VERY
BRIEF -- I'M
JOHN DORY ON BEHALF OF THE CIVIL
JUSTICE ASSOCIATION OF
CALIFORNIA I'M HERE AND UP AT
THE DS JUST TO MAKE SURE.
THAT IT'S CLEAR THAT THIS WILL
BE A LITIGATION BOOM --
I UNFORTUNATELY THE WAY THAT THE
SYSTEM IS WORKING IN THIS --
THIS WOLF QUALIFY UNDER
SEVENTEEN AND TRYNG TO MAKE
SENSE OF THAT UMBEL COSTS --
MILLIONS OF DOLLARS IN A
UNNECESSARY EXPENSES AND SO ON I
APPRECIATE THE EFFORTS TO LIMIT
ON THE PRIVATE RIGHT OF ACTION
BUT BECAUSE OF THE WAY IT'S
STRUCTURED.
ON A THAT IS STILL IN THE BILL
AND WE REMAINED VERY CONCERNED
THANK YOU FOR YOUR INDULGENCE
MISTER.
THANK YOU KNOW WE'LL GO TO
ADDITIONAL WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION I'LL REMIND YOU --
ONLY TO STATE YOUR NAME
AFFILIATION AND POSITION PLEASE.
MISTER CHAIRMAN WAS DOMINIC MARI
HERE ON BEHALF OF FRONTIER
COMMUNICATIONS IN OPPOSITION TO
THE BILL.
MISTER CHAIRMAN FRED MAIN ON
BEHALF OF THE CHAMBER OF
COMMERCE ALLIANCE OF VENTURE AND
SANTA BARBARA COUNTY IN
OPPOSITION.
SARAH BOOT ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA CHAMBER OF COMMERCE
IN OPPOSITION.
GOOD AFTERNOON BRENDA PAMI NAM
HAVE A SPRINT IN OPPOSITION.
HEIDI PURSUE LEON BEHALF OF
VERIZON IN OPPOSITION.
HILL ON THE FENCE ON BEHALF OF
CAL COM RURAL TELEPHONE
COMPANIES IN OPPOSITION.
PAM LIMITS ON BEHALF OF
CONSOLIDATED COMMUNICATIONS IN
OPPOSITION.
SUSAN PETERSON LIPPER ON BEHALF
OF T. MOBILE ALSO IN OPPOSITION.
MARGARET GLAD SHE'D HAVE COMCAST
OPPOSITION.
LET SHEPHERD REPRESENTING THE
ASIA PACIFIC ATLANTIC CHAMBER OF
COMMERCE IN OPPOSITION.
DRILL COOK FOR THE CALIFORNIA
MANUFACTURERS IN TECHNOLOGY
ASSOCIATION IN OPPOSITION.
HE CUCAMONGA* COMMUNICATIONS
IN OPPOSITION.
WHERE TOP ON BEHALF OF ORANGE
COUNTY BUSINESS COUNCIL IN
OPPOSITION?
MISTER CHAIRMAN I DO APOLOGIZE I
WAS IN ANOTHER COMMITTEE JAMES
JACK HERE FOR CAL TELL IN
SUPPORT THANK YOU.
THANK YOU PRONG LINE.
WE WANT TO NOW GO TO QUESTIONS
AND ANSWER FROM COMMITTEE
MEMBERS AND MISS --
MISTER VICE CHAIR YOU HAD THE
FIRST QUESTION.
I THANK YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN SO
WE HAVE A VERY ROBUST DISCUSSION
ABOUT.
THE WHOLE CONCEPT OF INTERNET
NEUTRALITY THE LAST TIME THIS
BILL WAS IN THE COMMITTEE SO.
I WANT TO FORGO THAT SINCE WE
PARTY DISCUSSED IT WHICH MEANS
YOU DON'T HAVE TO LISTEN TO MY
BRIDGE METAPHOR.
AGAIN.
BUT I JUST WANTED TO FOCUS ON
THE ASPECTS OF THE BILL WOULD
HAVE CHANGED SINCE THEN AND I I
SPECIFICALLY WANT TO TALK ABOUT.
THE PRACTICE OF ZERO RATING
BECAUSE TO ME.
THE DEBATE WE HAD BEFORE WE WERE
TALKING ABOUT BUSINESS PRACTICES
OF INTERNET SERVICE PROVIDERS WE
CAN COUNT HAVE A PHILOSOPHICAL
DISCUSSION ABOUT THAT BUT WHEN
WE'RE TALKING ABOUT ZERO RATING
WORK PROHIBITING A PRACTICE
[inaudible]
THAT.
THE RESULT OF WHICH IS GOING TO
BE TO TAKE MONEY OUT OF
CONSUMERS' POCKETS.
SO IF YOU'RE IF YOU'RE SAYING TO
INTERNET SERVICE PROVIDER.
YOU'RE CURRENTLY PROVIDING A
SERVICE FOR FREE YOU CAN'T TO
PROVIDE THAT SERVICE FOR FOR YOU
HAVE TO PAY FOR IT.
BUT THAT IS VERY CONCERNING TO
ME SO I WONDERED IF WE COULD
HAVE A LITTLE BIT MORE DRILL
DOWN ON WHY EXACTLY ZERO RATINGS
SO PERNICIOUS.
AND WHY YOU FELT IT NECESSARY TO
PUT THAT INTO THE BILL A SURE I
WILL ARE COMMON IN MIND THAT
WE'RE GONNA ASK QUESTIONS
THROUGH THE CHAIR HAS CUSTOMARY
[inaudible]
MAY CONTINUE.
KAREN THANK YOU ARE ALL COMMENT
ON THAT AND THEN I'LL ASK --
EYEWITNESSES TO ADD ON I ZERO
RATING WHICH IS CALLED FREE DATA
PLANS IT'S FREE DATA THAT'S NOT
REALLY FREE --
AS INITIAL POLICY MATTER UP WHAT
ZERO RATING DOES.
IS IT REDUCES COMPETITION.
WHICH DRIVES UP COSTS OVERTIME
SO IF DOT COM AU I DON'T A PECAN
INDIVIDUAL BUSES RAN WITH A
VERIZON THEY'RE NOT GOING TO
THINK THAT THAT'S A VERIZON --
SAYS -- BUT
CIVIL RIGHTS AND SAYS IF YOU USE.
UP MY VIDEO PRODUCT IT DOESN'T
COUNTING ANSWER DATA IF YOU USE
AND THESE COMPETITORS PRODUCTS
ACCOUNTS AGAINST HER DATA.
HOT DOT IS HIGHLY ANTI
COMPETITIVE WORK HEY NETFLIX IS
PAYING US A BUNCH OF MONEY SOBRE
ZERO RATING THEIR PRODUCT NO
DATE IF USE NETFLIX.
IF YOU USE THE START UP OVER
HERE THAT'S OFFERING COMPETITORS
STREAM PRODUCT COULD ACCOUNT
AGAINST YOUR DATA.
AND STREAMING OF COURSE IS VERY
DATA INTENSIVE AND SO WHAT IT
DOES OVER TIME IT REDUCES
COMPETITION IT SQUEEZES THE
SMALLER AND MID SIZE COMPANIES.
ADULTS I AND IT PICKS WINNERS
AND LOSERS AMONG COMPETITION IS
REDUCED THAT OVER TIME RAISES
PRICES FOR CONSUMERS WE ALSO
KNOW BASED ON EXPERIENCES IN
COUNTRIES THAT HAVE RESTRICTED
THIS KIND OF ABUSIVE ZERO RATING.
ANTICOMPETITIVE ZERO RATING ODD
THAT WHEN ZERO RATING IS
RESTRICTED [inaudible]
THEN COST OF AN UNLIMITED DATA
PLAN COLLAPSES GO DOWN
DRAMATICALLY SO THAT'S A SAVINGS
FOR CONSUMER.
AND DATA CAPS GO UP SO CONSUMERS
GET MORE DATA FOR THE SAME PRICE
AND THE REASON FOR THAT IS ZERO
RATING SO CALLED PRE DATA PLANS
WHERE THEY MAKE A LOT OF MONEY
OFF THOSE PLANS FRANK ABOUT IS
GIVING AWAY FREE DATA SORT OF A
MISNOMER.
THEY'RE MAKING A LOT OF MONEY
OFF OF THOSE QUORUM CORPORATE
DATA PLANS.
I PRUDENT PLANS HAVE VALUE ZERO
RATING HAS VALUE ONLY IF DATA
CAPS ARE KEPT LOW.
IF YOU MAKE IT EASY FOR WORKING
CLASS AND LOW INCOME PEOPLE TO
BUY UNLIMITED OR HIGH DATA CUT
PLANS IF YOU MAKE IT AN
EXPENSIVE. ZERO RATING HAS NO
VALUE BECAUSE YOU HAVE ALL THE
DATA YOU NEED TO GO WHERE EVER
YOU GO.
CAN ONLY HAS VALUE WHEN THEY
MAKE IT IMPOSSIBLE FOR MIDDLE
INCOME LOW INCOME PEOPLE TO BUY
UNLIMITED DATA PLANS.
AND WHERE THEY HAVE LOW DATA
CUTS SO ZERO RATING IS INTENSELY
ANTI CONSUMER.
IT REDUCES CONSUMER CHOICE A
REDUCES COMPETITION WHICH RAISES
PRICES I WANNA COMPANY IF A
NETFLIX IS PAYING A TON OF MONEY
TO BE ZERO RATED.
WHERE IS WHERE THEY PASSING THAT
THROUGH?
THEIR CUSTOMERS ARE GONNA END UP
PAYING MORE BUT IN THE END WHAT
THIS BILL IS A BALLOT AND WHAT
ZERO RATING IN PARTICULAR IS
ABOUT IS AVOIDING --
THAT WITH AND WITH ALL RESPECT
TO THE CABLE ASSOCIATION ACCESS
TO THE CABLE CUSTOMER AT THEIR
CAPITALIZATION OF THE INTERNET.
I THINK PEOPLE ARE VERY USED TO
GOING ONTO THE INTERNET I'M
GOING WHERE EVER THEY WANT TO GO
NOT BEING LIMITED WE ARE HEADED
TOWARDS A REGIME IN ZERO RATING
IS AT THE HEART OF THIS.
WHERE PEOPLE ARE GOING TO PUSH
IN THE PLANS WHERE OKAY THIS IS
YOUR PLAN HERE THE FIVE NEW SO
NEW SITES THAT ARE PART OF YOUR
PLAN?
HERE THE THREE SHOPPING SITES IN
ONE SEARCH ENGINE.
AYE IT'S A LITTLE BIT LIKE --
AND JONES SAWYER MENTIONED THIS
TO ME IV ISSUE OF WHEN --
YOU COULDN'T WATCH CAN'T WATCH
DODGERS GAMES OFF CABLE AYE IN
LOS ANGELES.
THAT'S WHERE WE'RE HEADED
TOWARDS WITH A COMBINATION OF
LACK OF THE BLOCKING RULES.
I AND ZERO RATING OUGHT THAT WE
CAN'T DECIDE WHAT WE WANT TO SEE
WHERE WE WANNA GO WE'RE BEING
TOLD AND MANIPULATED AND ZERO
RATING IS AT THE HEART OF THAT.
LET ME JUST JUMP IN AND IF THE
VICE CHAIR AND WEAK NEEDS ANY
FURTHER OF OUR QUESTIONS.
IT'S PROBABLY.
BUT I DO APPRECIATE THE ANSWER
TO THE QUESTION BUT YOU KNOW I I
HAVE.
TO OBJECT TO THE
CHARACTERIZATION OF ZERO RATINGS
ANTI COMPETITIVE.
A I MEAN IF YOU.
IF YOU USE THAT GENERALIZATION
THEM LOTS AND LOTS OF THINGS ARE
AT A COMPETITIVE I MEAN IF YOU.
IF YOU BUY A TICKET TO GOLDEN
ONE CENTER AND YOU GO WATCH A
BASKETBALL GAME AND YOU SEE AN
ADVERTISEMENT ON THE SIDE OF THE
ARENA.
YOU KNOW BASICALLY YOU'RE SAYING
WELL THAT'S ANTI COMPETITIVE THE
SHOULD BE ALLOWED TO DO THAT
BECAUSE THAT DISADVANTAGES THE
PEOPLE THAT ARE WILLING TO PAY
FOR THE ADVERTISING MEN I THINK
IT'S UNDERSTOOD.
AS A CONSUMER THAT THE VALUE OF
THAT ADVERTISING.
IS SUBSIDIZING THE TICKET PRICE
THAT YOU'RE PAYING.
THAT'S THE BUSINESS MODEL THAT
THE ARENA AND THE TEAM ARE ARE
DAUNTING.
AND I DON'T THINK IT'S THE
PURVIEW OF GOVERNMENT TO GET IN
THE WAY OF THAT ESPECIALLY WHEN
YOU'RE GONNA TELL A NETFLIX
CUSTOMER.
THAT THEY'RE NOT ALLOWED TO
WATCH NETFLIX.
WITHOUT EFFECTING THEIR DID THE
USING THE DATA UNDERNEATH OR
DATA CAP.
YEAH I MEAN IF IF YOU WANT TO
START A A MOBILE PHONE COMPANY
AND OFFER HIGHER DATA PLANS OF
YOUR FIRST CUSTOMER.
NOTHING TO BE GREAT BUT I MEAN
THAT'S THAT'S SOMETHING THAT
THAT THESE COMPANIES ALL COMPETE
IN A COMPETITIVE LANDSCAPE.
AND I AM THE THE AYE AYE WE ARE
INFERIORS AGREEMENT THAT.
WHAT THE MARKET REALLY NEEDS IS
MORE COMPETITION BECAUSE MORE
COMPETITION CLARIFIES A LOT OF
DIFFERENT ASPECTS AND IN
PARTICULAR FAIR PRICING?
WHICH IS SOMETHING THAT'S REALLY
HARD TO WRAP OUR ARMS AROUND.
I'M THE BIGGEST PROBLEM THAT I
HAVE WITH THE BAN ON ZERO
RATINGS THIS.
AND IT GOES BACK TO THE STUDY
THAT THAT I EIGHTEEN TI WAS
REFERENCING IT ENOUGH A IF YOU
HAVEN'T READ THE STUDY ANYONE
THAT HASN'T HIGHLY ENCOURAGE YOU
TO ITS ITS EYE OPENING.
UP AND BASICALLY WHAT IT SAYS IS
THAT FOR THE AVERAGE CUSTOMER.
YOU WILL COST THEM THIRTY TO
FIFTY DOLLARS A YEAR.
BY TAKING AWAY ZERO RATING BUT
AT THERE AND THAT'S SUBSTANTIAL
BUT WHAT'S REALLY EYE OPENING IS
THE FACT THAT A THIRD OF LOW
INCOME CUSTOMERS.
USE ONLY THEIR MOBILE PHONES. TO
ACCESS THE INTERNET.
AND FOR THOSE PEOPLE YOU WILL
COST THEM HUNDREDS OF DOLLARS A
YEAR THAT'S HUNDREDS OF DOLLARS
THAT THEY CAN'T AFFORD.
AND THIS GETS INTO SOMETHING
THAT I'M GET REALLY EMOTIONAL
THAT WHICH IS THE DECISIONS THAT
WE MAKE.
IN THIS BUILDING.
THAT RAISE THE COST OF LIVING IN
CALIFORNIA.
THE I MEAN I THINK WE'RE ALL
AWARE WE HAVE THE WORST POVERTY
OF ANY STATE THE COUNTRY HERE.
AND ONE OF THE REASONS THAT WE
DO.
IS THE DECISIONS THAT WE MAKE IN
THIS BUILDING THAT RAISE THE
COST OF LIVING THE U. S. CENSUS
BUREAU SAYS.
THE COST OF LIVING CALIFORNIANS
WAS IS WHAT'S DRIVING THAT
POVERTY RATE AND SO I I WANT US
TO THINK REALLY CAREFULLY.
ABOUT TAKING AN ACTION THAT'S
GOING TO COST LOW INCOME A
CONSUMERS HUNDREDS OF DOLLARS A
YEAR THAT'S THAT'S MY BIG
PROBLEM.
WITH THE BILL AND THAT'S WHY I
RESPECTFULLY ALL HAVE TO BE UP
IN OPPOSITION BUT I THINK YOU
VOTE FOR THE FOR MISTER TECH AND
MISTER CHAIRMAN IF I IF I MAY UM
TO THE VICE CHAIRMAN.
ADDITIONAL.
RESOURCES REQUIRED THIS BILL
DOES NOT BAN ZERO RATING.
IT BANS CERTAIN FORMS OF ZERO
RATING THERE OTHER FORMS THAT
ARE NOT BANNED.
A AND I WILL SAY THE GROUPS THAT
ADVOCATE ARGUMENTS IN POVERTY
LOW INCOME BILL THE GROUPS THAT
ADVOCATE FOR LOW INCOME PEOPLE
LIKE THE WESTERN CENTER --
ON LAW AND POVERTY AND OTHER ARE
NOT ONLY SUPPORTING THIS BILL
PUTS SEPARATELY.
AND EMPHATICALLY SUPPORTING THE
RESTRICTIONS ON ABUSIVE ZERO
RATE IN THE WESTERN CENTER ON
LAW AND POVERTY WOULD NOT BE
EMPHATICALLY SUPPORTING THE ZERO
SPECIFICALLY THAT ZERO RATING
PORTIONS OF THIS BILL.
IF THEY THOUGHT IT WOULD HURT
POOR PEOPLE IT'S POOR PEOPLE WHO
ARE BEING HURT WITH THE ZERO
RATING PLANS ON HEALTH WOULD I
ASK YOU ABOUT PRESIDENT YOU
COULD RESPOND THAT STUDY IN
PARTICULAR.
BECAUSE WE HAVE SOME MAJOR
ISSUES WITHOUT STUDY AND SO
FORTH.
I'M STUDY WITH PUT OUT THERE WE
DON'T AGREE WITH THAT AND WE
THINK IT'S NOT VALID.
I'M GONNA GO ON TO THE NEXT
QUESTION OF MISTER BONTA.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR AND THANK
YOU SENATOR WINNER FOR BRINGING
THIS THIS BILL FORWARD.
HEARD A NUMBER OF ARGUMENTS IN
THE OPPOSITION THAT I AND I
THINK IT'S REALLY IMPORTANT TO
JOIN ISSUE ON SOME THE KEY
ARGUMENTS BEING MADE AND AND
SORT OF HAVE BOTH SIDES ADDRESS
THEM SO WE CAN.
HERE THAT SORT OF A REBUTTAL OUR
RESPONSE TO SOME OF THE COMMENTS.
SO ONE WAY. TO OFFER THE CHAIR.
WERE INTERCONNECTION FEES AND
ZERO RATING IN.
THAT'S THE SEA TWENTY FIFTEEN
ORDER [inaudible]
IS.
THIS BILL PREEMPTED.
AND THE LEGAL.
YEAH I AM.
PLEASE COMMENT ON THE ISSUE OF
THE PATCHWORK OF OF HIS.
STATE REGULATORY REGIMES.
IT'S BEEN RAISED [inaudible]
I'M ANY.
RESPONSE TO THIS BILL HURTING
INNOVATION A TECHNOLOGICAL
ADVANCEMENT.
AND THEN THAT THIS IS GONNA LITA.
I HAVE A LOT OF LITIGATION.
SURE ARM IN TERMS OF
INTERCONNECTION I KNOW WE'VE
BEEN TALKING TO DIFFERENT
OFFICES WHICH WE SHOWED YOU A
LANGUAGE I FEEL THIS IS ONE OF
THE ODDEST ARGUMENTS I'VE EVER
HAD.
BECAUSE IN THE TWENTY FIFTEEN
ORDER THERE IS EXACT LANGUAGE
SAYING YOU CANNOT USE.
THE POINT OF INTERCONNECTION TO
EVADE THE PROTECTIONS IN THIS
ORDER WE HAVE ESSENTIALLY TAKEN
THAT EXACT LANGUAGE.
AND PUT IT INTO OUR BILL IT'S IN
THEIR IT'S IN WRITING.
AT AND I SO WITH THESE REPEATED
ARGUMENTS THAT IT WASN'T IN
THERE ARE JUST ARCHES FALSE IT
WAS ABSOLUTELY THERE.
ON IN TERMS OF ZERO RATING THE
FCC BEFORE THE CHANGE IN
ADMINISTRATION SHUT ENFORCEMENT
DOWN THE FCC WAS.
COMMENCING ENFORCEMENT UNDER THE
TWENTY FIFTEEN ORDER AGAINST
ISPS BASED ON ABUSIVE ZERO
RATING PLANS.
SAYING THAT SOME WERE OKAY.
BUT OTHERS VIOLATED THE NET
NEUTRALITY ORDER SO THAT THE FCC
ITSELF BEFORE THE CHANGE OF
ADMINISTRATION.
WAS MOVING FORWARD WITH ZERO
ENFORCEMENT UNDER THE TWENTY
FIFTEEN ORDER.
IN TERMS OF PREEMPTION COULD WE
EAT.
THEY ARE GOING TO SUE AND HAVE
EVERY RIGHT IN THE WORLD TO TEST
ANYTHING THAT THIS LEGISLATURE
PASSES AND QUIRK AND PEOPLE TEST
ARE BILLS IN COURT ALL THE TIME
AND SOMETIMES.
STATE PREVAILS SOMETIMES WE
DON'T WE THINK WE HAVE A STRONG
ARGUMENT THAT THIS IS NOT
PREEMPTED CONGRESS HAS NOT.
NOT PREEMPTED THE STATE'S
ABILITY TO ACT IN THIS AREA AND
THE FCC WE THINK WHEN THE FCC
ASSIGNED WE'RE ENDING OUR ROLE.
IN REGULATING THAT YOUR TRIAL
ATTY.
AYE WERE ISSUING A PRE AT
ADMINISTRATIVE PREEMPTION ON THE
FIFTY STATES OUT WE DON'T HAVE
THE POWER OUGHT TO DO THAT I'M
DEL CSU AND A COURT WILL
ULTIMATELY SIDE WE THINK IT'S
VERY DEFENSIBLE.
I IN TERMS OF THE PATCHWORK AYE
HUNT THIS IS ONE AREA WHERE WE A
100% AGREE IT IS FAR PREFERABLE
TO HAVING ONE UNIFORM GOOD NET
NEUTRALITY STANDARD IN THE U. S..
ARE AND HAD THE INTERNET SERVICE
PROVIDERS NOT GONE TO THE FCC.
AND TO THE NEW ADMINISTRATION
AND SAID PLEASE GET RID OF THE
TWENTY FIFTEEN OBAMA ORDER.
I WOULD I WOULD NOT BE HERE
TODAY I WOULD NOT HAVE
INTRODUCED THIS BILL.
I DID YOU KNOW THAT BE I INSTEAD
OF JUST.
KEEPING TWENTY FIFTEEN ORDER
INDUCED THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT
TO REPEAL IT AND THAT CREATED
STATE ACTION AND SO IT'S A
LITTLE BIT LIKE YOU KNOW.
THAT I I JUST DON'T BUY THAT
ARGUMENT.
AND THEN TERMS OF INNOVATION
FINALLY.
BUT LET'S BE REAL CLEAR. FOR
SEVERAL YEARS.
I AND FOR YEARS BEFORE THAT --
THESE.
HUGE CORPORATIONS WERE ACTING
UNDER NET NEUTRALITY RULES AND
MAKING [inaudible]
MASSIVE PROFITS THE TNT IS
PURCHASING TIME WARNER IF MY
NUMBERS ARE RIGHT FOR EIGHTY
FIVE BILLION DOLLARS IS WHAT
THEY'RE PAYING. TO BUY TIME
WARNER.
COMCAST OFFERED I BELIEVE SIXTY
FIVE BILLION DOLLARS TO BUY FOX
WHEN THAT DIDN'T WORK I THINK
THEY'RE BUYING A SKYPE FOR
THIRTY FOUR BILLION A HOBO
NUMBERS ARE APPROXIMATELY
CORRECT.
THIS IS NOT AN IMPOVERISHED
INDUSTRY THIS IS INDUSTRY THAT
IS MAKING.
A NOR AND AND THAT'S FINAL I'LL
HAVE THE DECORUM OF THE HOUSE SO
IF WE CAN KEEP OUR VOICES DOWN
BUT I WOULD APPRECIATE A AYE AYE
GOOD FOR SEEMS WE HAD THESE
RESTRICTIONS BAIT DID NOT.
I IMPEDE THE ABILITY OF THIS
INDUSTRY TO INVEST WHEN THEY
WERE IN PLACE BEFORE.
AND THIS INDUSTRY IS GOING TO BE
JUST FINE AFTER THESE
RESTRICTIONS I HOPE.
GOING TO AFFECT.
MISTER POTTER I'M SORRY OF
MISTER BONTA DID YOU HAVE A IS
NO NO I MEAN LET'S NOT THAT THE
TWO SHIPS PASSING IF IT IF IT IF
YOU WANT TO JOIN US.
ON ANY OF THE OTHER THE ISSUES
AND YOU KNOW.
I THINK US NOW GO --
TO MISTER PATTERSON TO ONE BE
FAIR TO ALL THE COMMITTEE
MEMBERS TO BE ABLE TO ASK YOUR
QUESTION.
THE MYSTERY PATTERSON POINT OF
VIEW AND I DRESSED UP MISTER
BONTA QUESTION YOU MAY PROCEED.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN AT
PENN THANK YOU FOR THE QUESTION
UP MY TESTIMONY.
A ZERO RATING I READ A QUOTE
DIRECTLY.
DIRECTLY FROM CHAIRMAN WHEELER I
ALSO SHE IS CALLING ON THE
EUROPEAN UNION.
BUT APPARENTLY THE NETHERLANDS
IN INDIA --
HAVE SOME SORT OF PROHIBITION ON
ZERO RATING OR SET SOME SORT OF
POLICIES I DON'T THINK THE
UNITED STATES SHOULD BE
FOLLOWING THOSE TWO PARTICULAR
COUNTRIES.
BUT I QUOTED THE EUROPEAN
UNION'S A QUOTE FROM JUST LAST
YEAR SAYING THEY SAW ZERO RATING
THEY SAW NO COMPETITIVE
DISADVANTAGES FROM ZERO RATING.
OUR I ALSO QUOTED DIRECTLY FROM
THE ORDER.
WHERE IT SAYS IT DOES NOT APPLY
OPEN INTERNET RULES TO
INTERCONNECTION?
THIS BILL WILL PROHIBIT THE
EXCHANGE OF DOLLARS BETWEEN
CONTENT PROVIDERS AND I S. P.'S
WE'RE TALKING ABOUT MASSIVE
NATIONAL CONTRACTS FOR ALL
CONTENT ON THE INTERNET AND THAT
HAS BEEN OPERATIONAL SINCE THE
BEGINNING OF THE INTERNET.
SO WE'RE TALKING ABOUT A RADICAL
CHANGE.
BUILT INTO THIS LEGISLATION AND
THEN FINALLY --
I'M GONNA AT THE ISSUE OF
PREEMPTION.
THE OBAMA ORDER INCLUDED EXACTLY
THE PREEMPTION LANGUAGE.
AND THE CURRENT ADMINISTRATION
INCLUDED PREEMPTION LANGUAGE AND
YOU DO NOT LOSE YOUR AUTHORITY
TO ASSERT PREEMPTION BECAUSE YOU
PURSUE A LIGHT TOUCH REGULATORY
MODEL.
INSTEAD OF A HEAVY TOUCH
REGULATORY MY SO PREEMPTION IS
THERE BOTH DEMOCRAT AND
REPUBLICAN ADMINISTRATIONS.
HAVE INCLUDED THAT IN THEIR
ORDERS SO THE VERY BIPARTISAN
ISSUE.
THEY'RE GETTING MISTER PATTERSON
HAD AN ADDITIONAL QUESTION --
YEAH UP.
I'D THEN I'D I HAVE TO THINK
LONG AND HARD ABOUT THIS --
AND MOST THE MEMBERS KNOW THAT I
COME FROM A LONG.
A HISTORY OF BROADCAST
EXPERIENCE.
AND WITH LOTS OF EXPERIENCE WITH
THE FEDERAL COMMUNICATIONS
COMMISSION.
AND WHAT IS TROUBLING ME.
OF THE MOST HERE.
I IS WITH RESPECT. TO FIFTY
DIFFERENT STATES.
ENGAGING IN A PATCHWORK.
I JUST THINK THAT IS INVITING A
LONG LONG SERIES.
OF LITIGATION A LONG LONG SERIES
OF OF HEARTACHE.
AND SO MEMBERS I THOUGHT YOU
KNOW I I REALLY THINK WE HAVE TO
THINK VERY VERY LONG AND HARD
ABOUT PASSING THIS BILL THROUGH.
I THINK THERE IS CLEARLY A
FEDERAL ISSUE A JURISDICTION
HERE.
I THINK TO THINK OTHERWISE IS TO
SUGGEST THAT THE INTERNET.
IS NOT THE MOST DATA.
WRITTEN LARGE EXAMPLE OF
INTERSTATE COMMERCE THAT THE
UNITED STATES HAS.
SO I THINK WE NEED TO BE CAREFUL
ABOUT THIS AND IN MAKING THE
DECISIONS THAT WERE.
I THINK THIS GUY CREATES MEANT
THAT.
SERIOUS UNCERTAINTY IN
CALIFORNIA. FOR A LONG LONG TIME
BUT I THINK.
RATHER THAN HELP THE INTERNET IS
ACTUALLY GOING TO DO TOUR
INVESTMENTS IN CALIFORNIA.
HERE'S MY BIGGER CAN BUT BIGGEST
CONCERN.
APART FROM THE PREEMPTION AND
APART FROM SOME OF THESE OTHER
[inaudible]
FACTORS.
WHAT IF WERE NOT CAREFUL WEEK WE
ARE GOING?
TO CREATIVE OUR STATE.
AN ISLAND OF ITS OWN REGULATIONS.
THAT IS GOING TO PENALIZE OUR
INTERNET USERS AND OUR
CONSTITUENTS I AND I'M I'M
STRUGGLING WITH.
THE NECESSITY.
FOR CALIFORNIA'S REACTION TO A
MORE FREE AND COMPETITIVE
INTERNET THIS LIGHT TOUCH.
APPROACH MEMBER LIKE I I I
HAVEN'T HAD A LOOK AT THIS
REALLY HARD AND LISTEN TO BOTH
SIDES.
BUT THE FACTS ARE REALLY SELF
EVIDENT.
UNDER LIGHT TOUCH REGULATION.
CALIFORNIA HOME INTERNET PRICES
DECREASED BY MORE THAN 50%.
FROM 200-082-2050.
AND ALTHOUGH MOBILE BROADBAND
INCREASES IN CALIFORNIA.
20005100% IN THAT SAME PERIOD.
THE WIRELESS BILLS ACTUALLY
DECREASED.
SOMEWHERE NEAR [inaudible]
415%.
I IN THE IN THE RUSH TO DO THIS.
I'M I'M I'M PLEADING WITH US TO
SLOW DOWN.
I'M PLEADING WITH US NOT TO LOSE
SIGHT.
OF THE FACT THAT LIGHT TOUCH
REGULATION.
HAS ALLOWED A FREE MARKET.
YOU PRODUCE RAPID INCREASES IN
INTERNET SPEEDS.
AND SIGNIFICANT DECREASES IN
INTERNET PRICES. TO ME MEMBERS
THIS LOOKS LIKE [inaudible]
PROGRESS.
I'M CONCERNED THIS BILL TAKES US
BACKWARDS AND I'M I'M GONNA HAVE
TO RESPECTFULLY VOTE NO.
THANK YOU FOR COMMENTS MISTER
PATTERSON A WE HAVE MISTER
HOLDEN FOLLOWED BY MR MATHIS.
THANK YOU SECURE.
MOST OF SENATOR I JUST A
QUESTION AS RELATES TO THE
TESTIMONY FROM THE OPPOSITION
AND THAT WAS RAISED ABOUT THE
CONTRACTS IN THE IMPLEMENTATION
TIME AND HOW THOSE CONTRACTS
THERE'S A CERTAIN DEGREE OF
EXPOSURE.
FOR THOSE ARE RELATIONSHIPS THAT
ARE ALREADY ESTABLISHED AND HAS
THERE BEEN ANY CONSIDERATION. TO
AN INLAND IMPLEMENTATION DATE.
THAT WOULD --
COINCIDE OR CREATE A BETTER
OPPORTUNITY FOR THOSE CONTRACTS
TO TO LINE UP WITH --
SO THE THE BILL IT IF THEY HAVE
A IF THERE THE CONTRACTUAL
ARRANGEMENT THE THIRD GOES
TOWARD THE END OF NEXT YEAR --
THE BILL AT PLEASE GONNA BE
CORRECTIVE ARMAND I DON'T
BELIEVE OVERRIDES THAT IT WOULD
BE FOR THE ENTER ENTRY INTO NEW.
OUR OUR CONTRACTS --
NO THIS IS ABOUT THE
INTERCONNECTION AGREEMENTS --
SO THE BUT IT.
SO I WOULD SAY FIRST.
THE BILL DOES NOT PROHIBIT
INTERCONNECTION AGREEMENTS AS
SUCH IT JUST BRINGS BACK THE
PART OF THE F. C. C.'S REGIME
THAT SAID YOU KIND OF VAGUE.
NET NEUTRALITY THROUGH INTO
CONNECTION PRACTICES AND IT SAYS
VERY EXPLICITLY THAT.
INTERCONNECTION AGREEMENTS THAT
DO NOT EVADE THE BILL SENATE
NEUTRALITY PROTECTIONS.
ARE NOT A PROBLEM.
SO THAT'S EXACTLY WHAT THE FCC
SAID IN ITS ORDER THE WAY IT'S
SET SPECIFICALLY YOU KNOW WE
HAVE.
IN PARAGRAPH ONE NINETY THREE WE
ARE NOW AVAILABLE TO HEAR
DISPUTES REGARDING ARRANGEMENTS
FOR THE EXCHANGE OF TRAFFIC WITH
A BROADBAND INTERNET ACCESS
PROVIDER RACE ON THE SECTIONS TO
ONE AND TWO TO ON A CASE BY CASE
BASIS AND THEN AND SECTION TO A
SIX THEY SAID.
WE WERE REALLY CONCERNED SO THAT
WE WANT TO MAKE SURE THAT YOU
KIND OF EIGHT ALL RULES THROUGH
INTO CONNECTION.
I WAS TUITION OF AUTHORITY OVER
INTERNET TRAFFIC EXCHANGE
PRACTICES ADDRESSES THAT
QUESTION BY PROVIDING US WITH
THE NECESSARY CASE BY CASE
ENFORCEMENT BOATS TO IDENTIFY
PRACTICES THAT MIGHT CONSTITUTE
SUCH INVASION ADDRESS THEM
[inaudible]
SO [inaudible]
NOW.
IF THE ICE PIECE THINK THEY WERE
VIA THEIR CONTRACTS WERE
VIOLATING THE FCC'S REGIME
BEFORE [inaudible]
THEN.
I DON'T KNOW BUT I WOULD SO
RIGHT NOW THE BILL WILL GO INTO
EFFECT AND REPLACE THE REGION
THAT WAS IN PLACE AND SO
THEREFORE THERE WAS NO.
SO FAR THE BILL HAS NOT HAD ANY
TRANSITION BECAUSE THE RULES
JUST WENT OUT OF AFFECT ON JUNE.
SEVENTEEN OR SOMETHING SO IT
DOESN'T SEEM AS IF IN THE
MEANTIME YOU WOULD HAVE ENTERED
INTO AGREEMENTS THAT WOULD NOT
VIOLATE.
THE TWENTY FIFTH AND I OPPOSE
THE AYE AYE BUT YOU DID FAIR TO
MISTER HOLDEN DID YOU DID YOU
WANT TO CONTINUE [inaudible]
BY WHAT.
YES IS THE ANSWER THE QUESTION
AYE AYE NOT BECAUSE I IT IT IT
IS.%
TRUE THAT IT WOULD GO INTO
EFFECT JANUARY FIRST AND WOULD
AFFECT OUR AND CONGRESS PLACE
BUT JUST BE VERY CLEAR.
THE FCC'S ORDER YOU TWENTY
FIFTEEN RULES WERE OFFICIALLY
GONE AS OF JUNE I THINK WAS NINE
OR TEN THROUGH THEIR BALLOTS
WHICH IS ALSO OF COURSE. FIVE
MONTHS AFTER WE INTRODUCED THIS
BILL THERE'S NO SICK DOES NOT
SITUATION WHERE PEOPLE DID
SOMETHING THAT WAS A SURPRISE
CHANGE IN THE REGULATORY.
ENVIRONMENT OTHER WERE BOUND BY
THESE RULES AROUND THAT OUR
CONNECTION WITH AND WE CAN READ
THE LANGUAGE OF WE GET OUT READ
IT BEFORE ABOUT HOW --
YOU THE OBAMA ORDER DID SELL YOU
CAN'T USE INTERCONNECTION TO
OBEY THEM THAT IS CROWDED
PROTECTIONS THAT WAS IN EFFECT
UNTIL.
RECENTLY I AM AND IT EXPIRED
WELL AFTER WE INTRODUCED THE
BILL WITH THOSE INTERCONNECTION
PROTECTION SO THEY CAN ARGUE
THAT THEY MADE DECISIONS WERE.
BY A CHANGE IN THE REGULATORY --
ENVIRONMENTS [inaudible]
USER.
I APPRECIATE THAT ITS I TAKE
YOUR IT YOU'RE PROBABLY OF
MISTER HOLTON COMMITTEE MEMBER
TO ASK TO THE BUDGET JUST TO TO
SEE IF THAT --
BECAUSE IT CAME UP IN THE SURE
THAT IS THAT THE UNDERSTANDING.
OF THAT MISTER CHAIRMAN MAC.
I WHAT WE RESPECTFULLY DISAGREE
FIRST OF ALL I AM CLEARLY WE
HAVE A DISAGREEMENT AS TO
WHETHER OR NOT THE TWENTY
FIFTEEN ORDER EXPLICITLY DE AND
INTERCONNECTION AGREEMENTS.
IT DID NOT.
WE HAVE INTERCONNECTION
AGREEMENTS IN PLACE THEY ARE NOT
STATE BY STATE AGREEMENTS THEY
ARE NATIONAL AGREEMENTS THEY
DON'T DISAPPEAR OVERNIGHT.
THE FACT THAT THIS BILL WAS
INTRODUCED WITH AN
INTERCONNECTION PROHIBITION AND
IT DOESN'T MEAN THAT WE
IMMEDIATELY MOVED TO START
DISMANTLING OF CONTRACTS.
THIS BILL WILL NOT ONLY BE
DISRUPTIVE TO THE MARKET WE HAVE
NO IDEA HOW WE'RE GOING TO GO
ABOUT UNTANGLING THOSE CONTRACTS
TO LOOK TO PUT A STRUCTURE IN
PLACE WITHIN THREE MONTHS
ASSUMING THAT THIS BILL IS
PASSED.
WITHIN THREE MONTHS IN ORDER TO
BE IN COMPLIANCE WITH ITS
PROHIBITION WHICH DID NOT
PREVIOUSLY EXIST BY JANUARY ONE
OF TWENTY NINETEEN DETERMINE IF
IF I MAY LOOK LET ME --
DIRECTED TO MR HOLDEN SINCE HE'S
ASKING THE QUESTIONS.
SO I'M ENJOYING THE CONVERSATION
THANK YOU AT AND BY.
A GUY Y. WHICH IS READ DIRECTLY
FROM THE TWENTY FIFTEEN ORDER
ARE SEARCHING OF AUTHORITY OVER
INTERNET TRAFFIC IT'S CHAIN
PRACTICES TRAFFIC IT'S CHANGE.
THAT INTERCONNECTION R.
ASSERTION OF AUTHORITY OVER
INTERNET TRAFFIC EXCHANGE
PRACTICES INTERCONNECTION
ADDRESSES THE QUESTION BY
PROVIDING US WITH THE NECESSARY
CASE BY CASE ENFORCEMENT HOLES.
TO IDENTIFY PRACTICES THAT MAY
CONSTITUTE SUCH INVASION OF NET
NEUTRALITY AND ADDRESS THEM --
AND SO THE THAT IT IT'S IN HERE.
AND OUR CONNECTION WAS IN THE
TWENTY FIFTEEN ORDER WE USE.
ESSENTIALLY THE SAME LANGUAGE.
TO BE VERY CLEAR ALSO BECAUSE
THEY KEEP SAYING THAT S. B.
TWENTY TWO BANDS INTERCONNECTION
AGREEMENTS THAT IS ABSOLUTELY
UNTRUE IT IS NOT DOWN.
INTERCONNECTION AGREEMENTS WHAT
IT SAYS IS YOU CAN'T USE.
A POINT AMERICAN ACTION. TO
EVADE NET NEUTRALITY.
INTERCONNECTION AGREEMENTS ARE
CRITICALLY IMPORTANT.
THAT'S HELD NETWORKS.
LINK UP BATTLE DATA FLOWS FROM
ONE NETWORK INTO COMCAST OR AT
AND T. AND THE CONSUMER.
SO WE'RE NOT TRYING TO BAN THEIR
COACH AGREEMENTS NOR DOES IT BUT
WHAT WE'RE SAYING IS IT WOULD
COMPLETELY DEFEAT NET NEUTRALITY.
IF THEY IF WE SAID HEY.
COMCAST OR A TNT YOU CAN'T
BLOCKER THROTTLE ON YOUR NETWORK.
BUT YOU CAN DO IT AT THE POINT
WHERE DATA FLOWS INTO YOUR
NETWORK THE POINT AMERICAN
ACTION.
THAT WOULD DEFEAT THE PURPOSE
THERE WOULD BE NO NET NEUTRALITY
I'M THAT'S WHY THE FCC SAID YOU
CAN'T USE APPOINT A BETTER
CONNECTION TO OBEY NET
NEUTRALITY.
AND WHAT WE DO HERE THIS IS NOT
BANNED INTERCONNECTION
AGREEMENTS ARE AND THEY WERE
BOUND BY THESE OBAMA RULES UNTIL --
A LITTLE OVER TWO MONTHS AGO IT
WAS JUST AT MID JUNE THAT THOSE
RULES EXPIRED.
AND ALREADY AT THAT POINT.
OUT OF THE SENATE AND WAS YOU
KNOW COME INTO TO THIS COMMITTEE
SO THERE'S NO SURPRISES HERE
THIS DOES NOT UP AND THEIR
INTERCONNECTION.
AGREEMENTS OUGHT WHAT THIS DOES
IS SAID YOU CANNOT SAY IF YOU
DON'T PAY ME THIS MONEY IN YOUR
TAX AGREEMENT ON THE BLOCK YOUR
WEBSITE.
I DON'T THINK WE WANT THAT TO
HAPPEN AND I DON'T WANT TO DELAY --
HAVING NOT AS A RULE SO THAT
THAT'S HOW WE USE HERE MISTER
HOLDEN.
WOULD WOULD YOU BE KIND OF
CLINICAL MYTH WITH MATH.
ARE YOU OKAY WITHOUT.
CONTINUOUS HOLDEN I APOLOGIZE
YEAH I I APPRECIATE THE THE
RESPONSE THAT'S VERY HELPFUL --
IF THERE'S SOMETHING THAT WE
HAVEN'T ALREADY HEARD THE HEALTH
WELL MISTER CHAIRMAN I THINK THE
SENATOR WIENER JUST HIT THE NAIL
ON THE HEAD.
WHAT THE BILL PROHIBITS?
IS A IS IS PAYMENT FOR DELIVERY
OF THE CONTENT.
STORY KLEE THE INTERCONNECTION
AGREEMENT THE ESSENCE OF THE
AGREEMENT IS THE CONTENT
PROVIDER WHETHER IT'S AN AMAZON
OR GOOGLE OR SMALL CARRIER OR
NETFLIX EXETER.
ENTERS INTO A CONTRACT WITH THE
INTERNET SERVICE PROVIDERS AND
THEY PAY FOR VOTE DELIVERY.
OF THAT CONTENT TO THE END USER
THOSE DOLLARS ARE USED FOR
OPERATION MAINTENANCE AND
EXPANSIONS OF THE NETWORK THEIR
ECONOMIC AGREEMENTS TO ENSURE
THE CONTENT PROVIDER IS ABLE TO
GET THEIR CONTENT TO THE END
USER.
EXACTLY AS THEY'VE DESIGNED THAT
CONTENT AND THAT THE END USER
HAS AN EXCELLENT EXPERIENCE IF
YOU NOTICE OVER THE YEARS.
DELIVERY OF CONTENT HAS GOTTEN
BETTER AND BETTER IT IS BECAUSE
OF THESE ENTERED IT
INTERCONNECTION AGREEMENTS.
AND THOSE INCLUDE PAYMENT FOR
DELIVERY IF YOU REMOVE PAYMENT
FOR DELIVERY AS THIS BILL DOES.
THEN WE ENTER INTO AN AGREEMENT
AND DELIVER FOR FREE WHERE DOES
THE EXPENSE OCCUR IT GETS MOVED
TO THE END USER ONE WAY OR THE
OTHER AND THEN FINALLY THE OTHER
COMMENT I'VE HAD MY TESTIMONY
MULTIPLE TIMES.
THE QUOTE FROM THE FROM THE FCC
THIS ORDER DOES NOT APPLY OPEN
INTERNET RULES TO INNER
CONNECTION THE FCC WAS CLEARED
TWO THOUSAND FIFTEEN MY LAST
OBSERVATION.
IS THE S. WE OPERATED BEFORE TWO
THOUSAND FIFTEEN WITHOUT THE
OBAMA RULES WE OPERATED FOR TWO
AND A HALF YEARS WITH THE OBAMA
RULES AND TODAY WE OPERATE UNDER
THE CURRENT FCC RULES WE DID NOT
CHANGE.
ANY INTERCONNECTION AGREEMENTS
REGARDLESS OF WHICH REGIME WE
OPERATED UNDER THEREFORE THEY
DID NOT PROHIBIT.
PAYMENT FOR INTERCONNECTION
AGREEMENTS THANK YOU VERY MUCH
[inaudible]
IT.
ANY ADDITIONAL QUESTIONS.
I DO KNOW IF YOU RAISE YOUR HAND
AND I APOLOGIZE.
I MISSED RODRIGUEZ.
YEAH I WANT TO THANK A SENATOR
FOR BRING IN THIS SO.
ISSUE TO OUR ATTENTION OBVIOUS
IT THAT'S VERY.
UNIQUE AND CHALLENGING OTHERS A
LOT OF MOVING PARTS VERY
COMPLICATED ON HONDA.
SHARE WHAT'S REALLY THAT THE
ISSUES ARE AND WHAT'S REALLY
HAPPENING BUT SOMETHING DEAR TO
ME AND BECAUSE MY BACKGROUND
YEAH MASS IN IN WORKING WITH.
FIRST RESPONDERS FOR MANY YEARS.
A VERY --
CONCERNED ABOUT THE ARTICLE
TODAY IN LA TIMES --
CHAIR IF I CAN JUST READ A FEW
SENTENCES FROM THAT [inaudible]
THAT'S OKAY --
THE FIRST SINCE IN THE ALLEY CAO
LA TIMES TODAY.
SANTA CLARA FOR SANTA CLARA
COUNTY FIREFIGHTERS WERE
CRITICALLY HINDERED BY
INADEQUATE INTERNET SERVICE
WHILE THEY HELP BATTLE THE
MASSIVE MENDOCINO COMPLEX FIRE.
IN JULY.
THIS THROTTLING HAVE A
SIGNIFICANT IMPACT IN OUR
ABILITY TO PROVIDE EMERGENCY
SERVICES --
WOODEN QUAN ON AUNT BUT OUT OF
THAT IN TRYING TO GET MORE WHAT
REALLY HAPPENED IS CONCERNING TO
ME -- IT'S
KIND YOU --
AN ISSUE THAT IT'S BEEN BROUGHT
TO MY ATTENTION THAT JUST TRYING.
SEE WHAT DOES THAT MEAN COMPARE
WE'RE DOING HERE BUT QUICK
KROGER SUMS IT THERE'S AN ISSUE
HERE.
IF THE FOR FIRST RESPONDERS.
ARE BEING HINDERED BY THE TYPE
OF SERVICE AND CONNECTIONS AND
SPEEDS.
IF IT'S HAPPENING TO THEM.
AND THE MOST CRUCIAL NEED OF
DOING THEIR JOB OF PROTECTING
OUR PEOPLE AND SAVING LIVES AYE
I'M HAVING A PROBLEM WITH THAT
IT'S JUST MORE OF A COMMENT.
CONCERN AND I DON'T KNOW IF
ANYBODY WOULD LIKE TO TO ADDRESS
THAT -- BUT
I JUST WANTED IT --
TO SPEAK ON BEHALF OF THIS
ARTICLE TODAY THAT. TO ME IT'S
KIND OF INTERESTING AS WERE.
TALKING ABOUT THIS A IT BILL
TODAY IT'S ONE MAKE SURE WE
FULFILL YOUR WISH ON THIS
RODRIGUEZ WAS IT WAS A DIRECTION --
WAS A QUESTION DIRECTED TOWARDS
A MISTER WE KNOW THE AUTHOR OR
WAS DIRECTED TO VERIZON I THINK
IT'S JUST A COMMENT IN GENERAL.
AND OUT OF ANYBODY WANTED TO
SPEAK TO IT BUT IT'S JUST
BECAUSE THAT WAS TODAY IT CAN
WORK YOU KNOW IT'S KIND OF
UNIQUE I GUESS THAT WE'RE
TALKING ABOUT SUBSTANCE HONORED.
THAT WOULD PROBABLY HAVE AN
IMPACT WITH THAT IF YOU LOSE YOU
AGAIN ASK THE AUTHOR IF YOU
LIKED IT TOO AND OTHER MEMBERS
TO COMMENT CONCERNED
[inaudible]
LET ME.
I DO THINK THAT IT IS VERY
VITALLY IMPORTANT THAT WE HEAR.
FROM THE PROVIDER.
TERMS OF BEING USED WITH RESPECT
TO THROTTLING IT'S AFTER.
IN THE VERY ARTICLE THERE IS AN
EXPLANATION OF WHAT HAPPENED AND
I THINK WE NEED TO HEAR THAT IN
ORDER TO BE FAIR WITH RESPECTED
THIS AND I'D LIKE TO HAVE MR
MATTERS AND I WAS GONNA BE MY
NEXT POINT.
SO THANK YOU BUT BUT WHAT I DO
ONE ON ENSURES THAT WE DON'T END
UP IN A CONVERSATION THAT IS NOT
EXACTLY PART INTO THE BILL
BEFORE US BECAUSE I BELIEVE THAT
WILL BE A SELECT COMMITTEE
HEARING --
DOWN THE LINE IF I'M STICKING
DIRECTLY SPECIFIC TO THAT ISSUE
YOU WANT TO GIVE THE OPPORTUNITY
BONDS IF YOU WISH TO RESPOND.
I AND THEN I WANT TO MOVE
CONTINUE BACK ON ON THE BILL IF
IT'S OKAY WITH EVERYONE NOTHING
[inaudible]
I'VE YOU YOU MAY IF YOU LIKE I
IN THE SURE I ABOUT I WOULD HAVE
TO DIE ODD NUMBERS OF THAT WAS
VERY DISTURBING I THINK TO TO
MANY OF US.
ARE AND I I DON'T YOU KNOW I
BEFORE I WOULD.
NO COMMENT DEFINITIVELY ON WHAT
HAPPENED I WOULD OF COURSE WANT
TO KNOW.
EXACTLY WHAT HAPPENED BEYOND WHY
I'VE READ IN THE PRESS ABOUT
WHAT I WILL SAY IS.
REGARDLESS I KNOW VERIZON HAS
ITS ITS JOB ITS TAKE ON WHAT
HAPPENED AND WHY.
I I I I DO THINK THAT IT WAS
ANOTHER IT WAS.
SORT OF EVIDENCE ONCE AGAIN OF
HOW CRITICALLY IMPORTANT
INTERNET ACCESS IS TO IT
EVERYTHING INCLUDING PUBLIC
SAFETY.
I AND THAT WHAT HAPPENS WHEN YOU
DO HAVE THROTTLING WHATEVER THE
REASON WAS FOR THE THROTTLING --
THAT IT IS IT IT CREATES
PROBLEMS AND IN TERMS OF SLOWING
DOWN UP BUT AGAIN I AYE BECAUSE
ALL I KNOW IS WHAT I READ IN THE
PRESS I DON'T WANNA DEFINITIVELY
COMMENT ON MISTER CHAIRMAN
MEMBERS HOW DEEP ARE SILLY ON
BEHALF OF VERIZON WE APPRECIATE
THE OPPORTUNITY TO RESPOND. TO
THE QUESTION.
I'M VERIZON IT'S STRONGLY
COMMITTED TO PUBLIC SAFETY AND
THIS WAS VERY TROUBLING THING TO
LEARN YESTERDAY.
I AND THIS PARTICULAR SITUATION.
HOWEVER HAS NOTHING TO DO WITH
THE NET NEUTRALITY.
NET NEUTRALITY IS WE HEARD HERE
EARLIER TODAY ADDRESSES CONTENT
DISCRIMINATION.
I AND THERE'S NOT EVEN AN
ALLEGATION HERE THAT THIS WAS I
AM REDUCING SPEED BASED ON
CONTENT.
MR IS CONTENT NEUTRAL BASED ON A
CUSTOMER.
AYE CHOOSING A DATA PLAN THAT
HIDE A DATA ALLOTMENT AND WHEN
THEY REACH THEIR DATA ALLOTMENT
AS AGREED.
TO BE SPEED WAS REDUCED.
I VERIZON DOES HAVE --
IN INTENDED PRACTICE INTERNALLY
WHEREBY AN EMERGENCY SITUATION
CAN TRIGGER.
I'M THE ESCALATION OF A
SITUATION LIKE THIS AND ANY
LIMITATIONS ON THAT PARTICULAR
DATA PLAN CAN BE REMOVED.
IN THIS SITUATION I BAD CUSTOMER
SERVICE REPRESENTATIVE WAS NOT
AWARE OF THAT CIRCUMSTANCE AND
BATS AND INTENDED PRACTICE.
AND SO VERIZON HAS ACKNOWLEDGED
THAT THIS WAS A MISTAKE WE ARE
ACTIVELY I'M LOOKING INTO THE
SITUATION NOW AND TAKING
PROACTIVE STEPS TO ADDRESS THIS
MOVING FORWARD [inaudible]
I AND WE LOOK FORWARD TO
FOLLOWING UP WITH EVERY MEMBER
OF THIS COMMITTEE TO INFORM YOU
OF WHAT PROACTIVE STEPS WE WILL
BE TAKING.
HOWEVER THIS IS A VERY SEPARATE
ISSUE FROM THE NET NEUTRALITY
DEBATE WE'RE HAVING AND THESE
PIECES OF LEGISLATION THAT THE
COMMITTEE IS HEARING TODAY.
THANK YOU ARE THERE ANY FURTHER
QUESTIONS FROM COMMITTEE MEMBERS.
I DON'T SEE ANY --
THEREFORE.
ON ANY.
IT DOES THE AUTHOR WISH TO CLOSE.
PAT YES THANK YOU ARE MISTER
CHAIRMAN I WANT TO THANK
COMMITTEE MEMBERS BOTH.
THOSE WHO ARE SUPPORTIVE AND
THOSE WHO ARE NOT FOR THE VERY
THOUGHTFUL.
OUR DISCUSSION TODAY ARE WE ARE
YOU KNOW LIKE I SAID BEFORE I
REALLY WISH.
I THAT I COULD USE THIS BILL FOR
SOMETHING ELSE ANA AND I WISH
THAT WE HAD A FEDERAL PROTECTION
TO PLACE.
ARE BY WHAT HAPPENED DIE IN
DECEMBER OF LAST YEAR THAT TOOK
EFFECT IN JUNE OF THIS YEAR WAS
NOT JUST THE REPEAL OF THE
TWENTY FIFTEEN ORDER.
IT WAS BASICALLY THE APPEAL
REPEAL OF I THINK ABOUT FIFTEEN
YEARS WORTH OF FCC RULES ARE ON
THAT NEUTRALITY BECAUSE TWENTY
FIFTEEN WAS NOT THE BEGINNING --
THERE WERE RULES IN PLACE BEFORE
IT WAS ALL WHITE TO WHITE.
SO RIGHT NOW IT IS EFFECTIVELY
IMPOSSIBLE UNDER FEDERAL LAW TO
ENFORCE NET NEUTRALITY BECAUSE
THE FEDERAL TRADE COMMISSION IS
NOT AN EFFECTIVE VENUE IT'S A
GREAT AGENCY BUT ON THIS ISSUE
IT'S NOT AN EFFECTIVE WAY TO DO
IT.
AYE AND SO WITHOUT THE STATE'S
STEPPING IN AND WE'RE NOT THE
FIRST. THREE STATES HAVE ALREADY
PASSED NET NEUTRALITY PROTECTIVE
LAWS ARE GOVERNORS HAVE ISSUED
EXECUTIVE ORDERS SO IN TERMS OF
THE PATCHWORK YOU KNOW WHICH
WHICH THE ISPS CREATED BY.
AND BY IN GETTING RID OF THE
FEDERAL PROTECTION THAT
PATCHWORK HAS BEGUN.
I AND I YOU KNOW I DO BELIEVE
THAT WE HAVE A RESPONSIBILITY IS
THE STATE TO PROTECT CONSUMERS
AND BUSINESSES HERE.
AYE DE ISPS WILL BE LLUVIA DOT
TO THIS BILL I WILL SAY FOR THE
RECORD THAT THE BEGINNING OF
THIS PROCESS EARLY IN THE YEAR --
WHEN -- DE
ICED HE'S RAISED YOU KNOW
THEY'RE THEY'RE GENERALIZED NON
SPECIFIC CONCERNS ABOUT
IMPLEMENTATION I SAID TO THEM IF
YOU HAVE TECHNICAL AMENDMENTS HE
WON A PROPOSED TO MAKE IT EASIER
FOR YOU TO EMPLOYMENT.
OR IF YOU THINK SOMETHING IS
DRAFTED IN A WAY THAT DOESN'T DO
WHAT WE SAY IT DOES.
PROVIDE US WITH SUGGESTIONS THEY
HAVE NEVER EVER EVER DONE THAT
AND THEY'VE DECLINED TO DO THAT --
AND THAT'S A PROG AS BUT THE
REALITY IS THEY CAN IMPLEMENT
THIS THEY'VE IMPLEMENTED BEFORE
THEY DON'T LIKE IT BUT THE
IMPLEMENTED BILL DO IT AGAIN.
AND WE WILL ALL BE BETTER OFF
FOR IT AND THEY WILL BE
PROFITABLE.
BUSINESSES TO FLIP A ARE TONIGHT.
I RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR RIVAL.
THANK YOU ARE MIND COMMITTEE
MEMBERS WE HAVE A MOTION ON SB A
TO TO THAT IS TO PASS AS AMENDED
THOUGH WITHIN WHICH TO
LEGISLATIVE COUNSEL THAT HAS
BEEN DISTRIBUTED --
WHICH REMOVES A PROVISION THE
BILL THAT REQUIRES A CONTINGENCY
ENACTMENT OF AS BEFORE SIXTY IN
THE MOTION IS DO PASSES
AMENDMENT.
A WE HAVE A FIRST AND A SECOND
IN ITS AND IT --
IT ENJOYS THE SUPPORT OF CHAIR --
MEN SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL.
MOTION IS DEPOSITS AMENDED
SANTIAGO AYE SANTIAGO AYE
OBERNOLTE.
OBERNOLTE NO BONTA [inaudible]
CERVANTES.
CERVANTES AYE EDUARDO GARCIA.
ADVOCACY AYE HOLDEN.
HOLDEN I KAMLAGER-DOVE.
KAMLAGER-DOVE I LOVE.
LOW AYE MAIENSCHEIN.
MAJOR NOT VOTING.
MATHIS [inaudible]
PATTERSON.
PATTERSON NO QUIRK SILVA.
QUIRK SILVA AYE RODRIGUEZ
[inaudible]
RODRIGUEZ I A TO THE MOTIONS OUT
A I THINK YOU'RE GONNA MOVE
ALONG TO HER SP UP [inaudible]
FOR SIXTY HONESTLY DELEON
.
OUR MIND THE AUDIENCE TO KEEP
YOUR VOICES DOWN I WANT TO
CONTINUE WITH THE BUSINESS OF
THE HOUSE.
ON MISTER DELEON YOU MAY PROCEED --
WHEN YOU CHOOSE TO GET MUCH OF A
MIXTURE OF MR VICE CHAIR
OBERNOLTE MISTER CHAIR OF SOME
TABLE VICTOR MUCH FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY TO PRESENT?
SO THE BILL FOR SIXTY I'M NOT
GETTING INTO.
A MUCH OF DETAILS OF HOW WE GOT
HERE WITH REGARDS TO THE A
DECISION MADE BY THE CHAIR OF
THE FCC.
A JUST RECENTLY WITH REGARDS TO
NET NEW VERY THOROUGH AND DEEP
DISCUSSION --
TODAY WITH REGARDS TO USE OF
SENATE BILL.
UP FROM --
MISTER WE TO WITH REGARDS TO NET
NEUTRALITY LUMIA WILL DO IS I'LL
CUT TO THE CHASE SOME MILK.
FOR SIXTY A HAS BEEN AMENDED TO
FOCUS ON REQUIRING ISPS INTERNET
SET INTERNET SERVICE PROVIDERS.
THAT ENTER INTO STATE CONTRACTS
THAT THEY IT HERE TO NET
NEUTRALITY PRINCIPLES BUT THIS
PROVISION ENSURE THAT THE PUBLIC
ENTITIES ONLY SPEND TAXPAYER
DOLLARS.
FUNDS ON CONTRACTS WITH ISPS THE
COMPLY WITH CALIFORNIA'S
COMPREHENSIVE NET NEUTRALITY
PROVISIONS.
AND IT GIVES OF CONSUMERS AND
GREATER TRANSPARENCY ABOUT THE
SERVICES WE ALL DEPEND ON
EVERYDAY LIFE --
SP FOUR SIXTY DOESN'T REQUIRE OR
CREATE ANY NEW REGULATORY
BUREAUCRACY.
IT FOCUSED OF FOCUSES IN
ENSURING THAT NEUTRALLY
VIOLATORS ARE PROHIBITED FROM
ENTERING INTO PUBLIC CONTRACTS
AS YOU KNOW --
THE SICK CALIFORNIA IS NOT IN
THE TELECOM BUSINESS WE
SUBCONTRACT.
WITH THE VARIOUS IDEAS OF ICE
PEOPLE RIDERS WHETHER IT'S A
CONTROVERSIAL CITY AGENCIES SUCH
AS FOR EXAMPLE THE DMV OR ARE OR
ITS OUR PRISON SYSTEM.
A MANY OF OUR STATE AGENCIES
HAVE THESE CONTRACTS WITH AYE
SPEEDS UP OUTSIDE A CONFERENCE
BECAUSE AGAIN WE ARE NOT IN THE
TELECOM BUSINESS WE SUBCONTRACT
TO FOLKS TO GIVE ACCESS TO
CONSUMERS.
OF THEREFORE WE WANT TO MAKE
SURE THAT --
ALRIGHT ISPS ADHERE TO THE
PRINCIPLES OF NET NEUTRALITY --
TODAY AND I RESPECTFULLY A
RESEARCHER MISTER VICE CHAIR
OVER OBERNOLTE IN MY COLLEAGUES
ON BOTH SIDES AL STRICKLIN SORT
AYE VOTE.
I THINK YOU MISTER DELEON I DO
ONE REMIND ON ALTHOUGH IT
DOESN'T LOOK LIKE IT MAY BE
NEEDED THAT EACH SIDE FOR
AGAINST WOULD BE A LOT OF TEN
MINUTES.
UP TO TWO MINUTES A PIECE AND
WE'RE JUST TWO MINUTES EACH.
WITH CHARM THE LIVE VIDEO AND
FRIEND INDIVIDUALS WHO WHO ARE
SUPPORTER IN OPPOSITION --
ONLY NAME AFFILIATION AND
POSITION I A REALIZE THAT YOU
WEREN'T HERE WHEN I'M WHEN I HAD
STATED THAT SO FOR YOUR BENEFIT
I WANT TO SAY THAT.
I ANY ADDITIONAL WITNESSES IN
SUPPORT.
BUT SHOULD ASK IF THERE'S ANY
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT BUT FOR
THEIR FOR A FORMALITY BUT NOW
ANY ADDITIONAL WITNESSES SUPPORT
I REMIND REMIND YOUR NAME
AFFILIATION A POSITION ONLY.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS
MITCH SNIDER WITH THE CALIFORNIA
LABOR FEDERATION ALSO IN SUPPORT.
YOU MISTER CHAIR AND A BUCK ON
BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
ASSOCIATION OF REALTORS IN
SUPPORT.
AT EMILY RASH EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR
OF CALPERS IN SUPPORT.
HEALTH PATRICK LANG I PRESENT
CAL FRANKLY MANY CAMPAIGN IN
STRONG SUPPORT.
ALAN CHAPMAN WITH INDIVISIBLE
SACRAMENTO IN STRONG SUPPORT.
CRISTINA CAHILL O. WITH
INDIVIDUAL SACRAMENTO IN SUPPORT
[inaudible]
IF YOU.
MEGAN SUBER'S ON BEHALF OF THE
WRITERS GUILD OF AMERICA WEST IN
SUPPORT.
GARY APPEL MILL VALLEY
CALIFORNIA CLEAN MONEY FUNDED
SUPPORT.
HURRY PSYCHE ALSO WITH
INDIVISIBLE SACRAMENTO IN STRONG
SUPPORT.
CALVIN QUICK BAY AREA STUDENT
ACTIVISTS STRONG SUPPORT.
JAMES JACK ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF
COMPETITIVE TELECOMMUNICATIONS
COMPANIES AND SUPPORT.
KAREN WILL SEND VALLEJO
CALIFORNIA IN STRONG SUPPORT.
SURE I. FITZGERALD VALLEJO
CALIFORNIA STRONG SUPPORT.
I'M CURRY MENLO PARK STRONG
SUPPORT.
SURELY SHILLING DUSKY CLEAN
MONEY AND ALSO MONEY OUT PEOPLE
IN PLEASANT HILL THANK YOU
STRONG SUPPORT.
KAREN BACK CALIFORNIA CLEAN
MONEY STRONG SUPPORT.
GRAHAM HERE WE WANT TO CREATE
STRONG SUPPORT.
THAT'S WHEN OAKLAND STRONG
SUPPORT.
RATE CHECK A TEENY CONCORD
STRONG SUPPORT.
ALLEN MODELING ALAMEDA STRONG
SUPPORT.
I'LL BE AN AVENUE --
CAUCUS --
BERKELEY STRONG SUPPORT THANK
YOU.
CHRIS HAMILTON'S NAY.
CHARITIES ON BEHALF OF THE
OFFICE A REPAIR ADVOCATES IN
SUPPORT.
MORNING CAR ALTERNATIVE STRATEGY
GROUP ON THE AFTER THE UTILITY
REFORM NETWORK AS WELL AS THE
COMMUNICATION WORKERS OF AMERICA
DISTRICT NINE IN SUPPORT.
VANESSA FALCONE ABOUT THE
ELECTRONIC FRONTIER FOUNDATION'S
SUPPORT AS WELL AS MY ALLERGIES
AND COLLEAGUES AT NEW MEDIA
RIGHTS FIGHT FOR THE FUTURE
CONSUMERS UNION GREEN LINING
INSTITUTE OAKLAND PRIVACY.
CREDO MOBILE AND COLOR CHANGE
OWN SUPPORT.
BARBOUR ANDERS FROM WATSONVILLE
CALIFORNIA I'M ACTIVISTS AND A
CONCERNED CITIZEN ASKING FOR
YOUR STRONG SUPPORT [inaudible]
THINK.
GLEN HELEN SACRAMENTO.
MEMBER ORGANIZE WHEN LEGISLATE
I'M IN STRONG SUPPORT.
AND HOW NOW THAT I'M
REPRESENTING NEXT ON CALIFORNIA
AND SUPPORT.
PAT LANG LOS ALTOS HILLS
CALIFORNIA CLEAN MONEY STRONG
SUPPORT THANK YOU.
BILL HILTON CALIFORNIA CLEAN
MONEY CAMPAIGN AND SUNNYVALE
SANTA CLARA COUNTY STRONG
SUPPORT.
PAUL AROUND ALL SAN FRANCISCO
CLEAN MY CAMPAIGN AND STRONG
SUPPORT.
JENNIFER TANNER FOR INDIVISIBLE
CALIFORNIA STATE STRONG AND
STRONG SUPPORT.
SAYS YOU ARE NOT FROM STOCKTON
OF CALIFORNIA CLEAN MONEY AND
SOMEONE CAME PEACE AND JUSTICE
STRONG SUPPORT.
MARY RYAN SAN FRANCISCO STRONG
SUPPORT.
GLORIA PURCELL BELMONT A
CALIFORNIA CLEAN MONEY CAMPAIGN
AND GREEN PARTY STRONG SUPPORT
PLEASE SUPPORT.
SARAH COST BE SACRAMENTO STRONG
SUPPORT --
ROBBER COMES SECOND APART TO
CLEAN UP ANY CAMPAIGN PASSED THE
BILL.
MARK THIS YEAR DAVIES CLEAN
CALIFORNIA CLEAN MONEY AND THEY
STEAL YOU IN SUPPORT.
LARRY BATHGATE OF MILL VALLEY
CALIFORNIA IN STRONG SUPPORT
THANK YOU.
CHRISTOPHER ALLEGE FROM SANDRA
FELL IN STRONG SUPPORT.
MARIO GUERRERO AND HAVE THE
CALIFORNIA FACULTY ASSOCIATION
SUPPORT.
MY DEAR GOVIND CARMICHAEL
CALIFORNIA POOR PEOPLE'S
CAMPAIGN IN SUPPORT.
PAUL KERR XIN MARTINEZ PLEASE DO
THE WILL OF THE PEOPLE IN PASS
THIS BILL.
CAN MCPHERSON OF CARMICHAEL
PLEASE SUPPORT THIS BILL
STRONGLY THANK YOU.
MICHAEL KARSH MARTINEZ
CALIFORNIA STRONG SUPPORT.
RAIN X. CALIFORNIA.
RIGHTS IN STRONG SUPPORT.
NANCY NFL ABOUT THOUGH SUPPORT.
JEAN CHECK A TEENY CONCORD
PLEASE SUPPORT.
ANGELINA ASIAN AMERICANS
ADVANCING JUSTICE CALIFORNIA
SONGS PART.
JUST PART LOW WESTERN CENTER ON
LAW AND POVERTY IN SUPPORT.
RENEE BARRETO SEIU CALIFORNIA
ALSO IN SUPPORT.
I LIKE YOU GET YOUR SHE CALLISON
FRANCISCO IN STRONG SUPPORT
THANK YOU.
MACKLIN SMALL BUSINESS OWNER AND
NUMBER OF THE AMERICAN
SUSTAINABLE BUSINESS COUNCIL IN
STRONG SUPPORT THANK YOU.
RALPH FINLEY SILICON VALLEY
CLEAN MONEY GROUP [inaudible]
STRONG SUPPORT [inaudible]
THESE.
DOCTOR MANDATE GALA INDIVISIBLE
EAST BAY AND AS POLLS HAVE TESCO
YET AGAIN THANKS CENTER DALY OWN
STRONG SUPPORT.
A CRACKDOWN HURLEY CALIFORNIA
CLEAN MONEY CAMPAIGN STRONG
SUPPORT THANK YOU.
ANY WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION
.
THANK YOU I JUST HAVE THE SAME
RULES APPLY.
YEAH THANK YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN
BILL DIVINE --
STILL WITH A TNT.
OF I THANKS FOR THE OPPORTUNITY
TO TESTIFY --
WE DO OPPOSE SP.
FOUR SIXTY WE BELIEVE IT'LL
INCREASE COSTS TO THE STATE
CAPITOL IN CROSS IT'LL INCREASE
COSTS TO A CONTRACTORS THE FCC
ORDER DID NOT INCLUDE.
ANY PROCUREMENT PROVISIONS STATE
LOCAL OR FEDERAL --
OBVIOUSLY S. B. FOR SIXTY DOES
APPLY NET NEUTRALITY RULES TO
PROCUREMENT HERE IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA.
AS MANY OF YOU MAY ALREADY KNOW --
ISPS CONTRACTING WITH THE STATE
ARE ALREADY [inaudible]
REQUIRED.
CERTIFY THAT THEY ARE IN FULL
COMPLIANCE.
ALL STATE AND FEDERAL LAWS
BEFORE THEY CAN ENGAGE IN A
CONTRACT TO PROVIDE SERVICES
WITH THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA.
SO WE THINK SB FOR SIXTY BY
BEING LINKED BACK TO SP A TWENTY
TWO ADDS A LEVEL OF CONFUSION.
ADDS A LEVEL OF UNCERTAINTY.
OPENS THE DOOR FOR GREATER
PROTEST OVER CONTRACTS AND
POSSIBLY PROTESTS DURING THE
LIFE OF THE CONTRACT.
OUT WE THINK THIS IS THAT'S COST.
TO BOTH THE CONTRACTOR AS WELL
AS THE STATE AND WE WOULD URGE
THE COMMITTEE TO REJECT THE BILL
THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
MISTER CHAIRMAN MEMBERS CAROLINE
MCINTYRE BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA CABLE AND
TELECOMMUNICATIONS ASSOCIATION
WE ARE ALSO OPPOSED TO THE BILL
FOR THE REASONS STATED TAB BY
EIGHTEEN T..
I WOULD SIMPLY ADD --
THAT WE DO BELIEVE THE STATE
HERE IS PREEMPTED THIS AWHILE
ADDS THIS BILL AND THE
PROVISIONS OF THE SPELL.
ARE CONTINGENT UPON THE
PROVISIONS OF THE BILL THAT WE
PREVIOUSLY DISCUSSED S. B. AND
EIGHTY TWO I WILL ALSO ADD THAT
THE COURTS HAVE ALSO RULED THAT
IT STATE CANNOT USE TO REGULATE
HAD DIRECT DIRECTLY INDIRECTLY
WHAT THEY ARE PROHIBITED.
FROM REGULATING DIRECTLY AND FOR
THOSE REASONS WE OPPOSE THIS.
MISTER CHAIR MEMBER STEVE
CARLSON PROCEED TIA WHERE THE
WIRELESS INDUSTRY TRADE
ASSOCIATION I'M I'D ADD TO THAT
THOUGH IF YOU'RE LOOKING AT HOW
MANY STATE AGENCIES.
THAT -- HAVE
[inaudible]
YOU KNOW.
COMPANIES THAT PROVIDE INTERNET
TO THEM THEY DO IT ALL THE TIME
PUBLIC SAFETY IS AT THE BIG ONE
A SILLY MEMBER RODRIGUEZ.
AND WE WOULD SUGGEST THAT THIS
IS GONNA MAKE THAT WAY MORE
COMPLICATED --
IT CHALLENGE THE ABILITY TO
PROVIDE THE SERVICES THAT WE
REALLY WANT.
IF YOU HAVE.
IT'S EIGHT FIFTY DIFFERENT STATE
AGENCIES ALL.
WITH THEIR OWN IDEA OF WHAT MAY
OR MAY NOT BE FULL COMPLIANCE
WITH THE INTERNET.
HOW WAS A CONTRACTOR GONNA KNOW
WHAT THEY'RE GONNA DO SO WE
THINK THAT'S GOING TO CREATE
ENORMOUS CONFUSION --
IT'S GONNA GO WELL BEYOND EVEN
BUT S. B. EIGHT TWENTY TWO IS
GOING TO DO WHICH IS GOING TO BE
SIGNIFICANT SO WE WOULD.
STRONGLY URGE THE CAN TO REJECT
THE THANK YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN
FIRST JOHN DORY ABOUT THE CIVIL
JUSTICE SO SHE ASIAN. ONE ECHO
LITTLE BIT OF WHAT MISTER
CARLSON SAID THERE --
BECAUSE FUNDAMENTALLY ON ITS OWN
FOR SIXTY DOESN'T HAVE A PRIOR
RIGHT PRIVATE RIGHT OF ACTION.
BUT BECAUSE EIGHT TWENTY TWO
WHICH IS LINKED TO DOES NOT ONLY
WILL YOU NOW HAVE EACH AGENCY
TRYING TO DETERMINE WHAT IS
COMPLIANCE --
YOU WILL HAVE INDIVIDUALS BEING
ABLE TO SUE AND CLAIM THAT
THERE'S NONCOMPLIANCE --
AND DE FOR EVERYBODY'S BEEN
LISTENING TO THESE HEARINGS
THERE'S DISAGREEMENT ABOUT WHAT --
THE LANGUAGE MEANS SO THAT'S
GOING TO HAVE TO BE RESOLVED.
OVER AND OVER AGAIN IN THE COURT
SETTING FOR THIS BILL TO
ACTUALLY BE EFFECTIVE AND SO FOR
THOSE REASONS WE THINK IT'S A
IT'S IT'S CREATING A SYSTEM THAT
WILL BE CONFUSING AND EXPENSIVE.
AND NOT A BENEFIT TO CONSUMERS.
ANY ADDITIONAL WITNESSES
OPPOSITE ON OPPOSITION.
HELLO MISS ON BEHALF OF
CONSOLIDATE COMMUNICATIONS IN
OPPOSITION.
SARAH BOOT WITH CAL CHAMBER IN
OUR GLASS YOU HAVE COMCAST.
HE WORKS HOW THRILLED YOUR
COMMUNICATIONS AND OFFICES.
Q. CARMONA WITH*
COMMUNICATIONS IN OPPOSITION.
BRENDA PALOMINO ON BEHALF OF
SPRINT ALSO IN OPPOSITION.
HOW YOU PERSONALLY ON BEHALF OF
VERIZON IN OPPOSITION?
WHERE A TOP ON BEHALF POINTS
COUNTY BUSINESS COUNCIL IN
OPPOSITION?
DROUGHT COOK FOR THE CALIFORNIA
MANUFACTURES A TECHNOLOGY
ASSOCIATION IN OPPOSITION.
UPON THE BENTSEN ON BEHALF OF
CAL CALM IN OPPOSITION.
SUSAN PETERSON LEPER ON BEHALF
OF T. MOBILE IN OPPOSITION.
ANY QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS FROM
COMMITTEE MEMBERS [inaudible]
SOMETIMES OBERNOLTE.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR A SENATOR
I TO QUESTION ABOUT THE
CONTINGENCY PROVISION OF THE
BILL.
SO THE CONTINGENCY PROVISION
SAYS THAT THE BILL IS CONTINGENT
ON THE ENACTMENT OF THE BILL WE
JUST HEARD S. B..
TWENTY TWO A A TWENTY TWO SAYS
THAT ALL INTERNET SERVICE
PROVIDERS HAVE TO ABIDE BY NET
NEUTRALITY YOUR BILL SAYS THAT.
INTERNET SERVICE PROVIDERS THAT
PROVIDE SERVICES TO GOVERNMENT
AGENCIES IN CALIFORNIA AFTER BY
DIED SO.
PRESUMABLY THAT SITUATION WOULD
ALREADY BE COVERED BY A TWENTY
TWO ARE CONFUSED ABOUT WHAT.
CLEARLY IF YOU.
THE BILL ITSELF --
POINT TO WHERE YOU'RE A CONFUSE
THAT AND I'LL SURELY THROUGH
THAT -- SO I
SECTION THREE SAYS THIS ACTUAL
BE OPERATIVE ONLY OF SENATE BILL
EIGHT TWENTY TWO OF THE TWO
THOUSAND SEVENTEEN EIGHTEEN
REGULAR SESSION IS ENACTED AND
BECOMES EFFECTIVE.
RIGHT SO EIGHT TWENTY TWO RT
SAYS THAT ALL INTERNET SERVICE
PROVIDERS IN CALIFORNIA WOULD
HAVE TO ABIDE BY THESE
REGULATIONS.
YOUR BILL SAYS ONLY THOSE WHO
PROVIDE SERVICES TO GOVERNMENT
AGENCIES WOULD SO WOULD SEEM
LIKE THE PROVISIONS OF YOUR BILL
PARTY COVERED BY A TWENTY TWO SO
I'M I'M I'M ASKING WHY YOUR BILL
IS NECESSARY.
AN ADDITIONAL REMEDY IT'S A BACK
UP OF WE WANT TO MAKE SURE THAT
WITH A IF THE NET NEUTRALITY
PRINCIPLES ARE ADOPTED AND COULD
FIGHT INTO LONG CALIFORNIA.
THAT WE DO HAVE AN ADDITIONAL
REMEDY THAT MAKES VERY CLEAR
EXPLICITLY CLEAR STATUTORILY.
THAT WE WON'T ENTER INTO ANY
CONTRACTS WITH ANY ISP PROVIDER.
OF WITH ANY STATE GOVERNMENT
AGENCY -- SO
IT'S AN ADDITIONAL BACKSTOPS IF
YOU WILL.
AND IF I COULD ADD TO AN AUTHOR
IS.
MISTER WILKEY WOULD DO I BUT I'M
STILL CONFUSED SO PLEASE LET ME
YEAH SO AND IT IS ONE ADDITIONAL
IT IS A REMEDY --
DOT THAT YOU VIOLATE IF YOU BUY
INDIVIDUALITY --
THERE'S YOUNG UNFAIR COMPETITION
LAW.
UP BUT YOU CAN ALSO THIS IS
ANOTHER.
THE WAY IN WHICH BID TO THE SIDE
OF TO VIOLATE THE LAW.
I'VE OTHER STATES THAT HAVE
ADOPTED EITHER LAWS OR EXECUTIVE
ORDERS AROUND THOSE HOLIDAY IF
I'M NOT MISTAKEN I BELIEVE
THEY'VE ALL INCLUDED.
UP BANDS ON PUBLIC CONTRACTS
BECAUSE OF THIS IS NOT A NEW
THING THEY WERE DOING IT THIS IS
WHAT THE STATES HAVE BEEN DOING.
A SINCE THE TRUMP FCC GOT RID OF
THAT OWNERS HOLIDAY TIME JOB SO
I UNDERSTAND.
IF THIS WAS AN INCREMENTAL STEP.
SO FOR EXAMPLE [inaudible]
WE'RE SAYING.
THE PUBLIC CAN DO WHAT THEY WANT
BUT WE THE STATE WITH TAXPAYER
DOLLARS ARE GOING TO INSIST THAT
OUR INTERNET SERVICE PROVIDERS
ABIDE BY THESE REGULATIONS THAT
I WOULD UNDERSTAND.
BUT WE'RE NOT DOING THAT INSTEAD
WERE SAYING EVERYBODY MUST ABIDE
AND THEN IN A SEPARATE PIECE OF
LEGISLATION.
WERE SAYING PEOPLE THEY PROVIDE
SERVICE TO THE STATE MUST ABIDE
AND THAT THAT'S WHY JUDGES DON'T
UNDERSTAND THE NEED OR THE I
WOULD BELIEVE THAT IF YOU
VIOLATE.
SP TWENTY TO THEN YOU'RE
RESTRICTED IN YOUR ABILITY TO
ENTER INTO A PSYCHOTIC UP OKAY
THAT MEANS THEWAY THE WAY I
READ IT TWENTY TWO IT SAYS THAT
THAT.
YOU CANNOT DO BUSINESS IN THE
STATE.
UNLESS YOU ABIDE BY THOSE
REGULATIONS SO I ENJOY THAT BUT
I HOPE MUMIA THAT MR BISOGNO
MORE TRY OKAY OF THE WILL OF
GIVE YOU MORE ONE MORE TRY TO
SEE IF A A IF IT'S MUCH MORE.
CLEAR AND I APOLOGIZE TO YOU FOR
ITS ITS IS NOT IS IS IS A CLEAR
PERHAPS IT SHOULD BE.
UP THE INDIVIDUAL CONSUMER.
SEPARATE FROM CONSUMER ITSELF.
BUT THIS MEASURE DOES
SPECIFICALLY HERE.
FOR SIXTY S. FOCUSES EXCLUSIVELY
ON OUR STATE AGENCIES IN
CALIFORNIA.
AND THOSE TAXPAYER DOLLARS THAT
WE UTILIZE THROUGH STATE BUDGET
THAT WE VOTE ON EITHER FOR OR
AGAINST.
SO IN A VERY EXPLICIT LANGUAGE
IT STATES CLEARLY THAT IF IN
FACT THE AYE SPEEDS DON'T ADHERE
TO NET NEUTRALITY PRINCIPLES
LAWS.
AS ARTICULATED IN THE VERY
ROBUST DEBATE UP PRIOR ON THE
SIMPLY --
STATE CENTERS A MEASURE S. B.
EIGHT TWENTY TWO A TWENTY TWO
THAT.
THE CITY CALIFORNIA WOULD BE
PROHIBITED.
MAJORING IN TO ANY TYPE OF
CONTRACTUAL OBLIGATION WITH
REGARDS TO ISPS AND THE INTERNET.
IF IN FACT THOSE NET NEUTRALITY
A PRINCIPLES ARE VIOLATED IN
CALIFORNIA IS VERY STRICT
PORTRAITURE OUT CENTER I
UNDERSTAND WHT THE BILL DOES I
JUST DON'T THINK IT DOES
ANYTHING THAT EIGHT TWENTY TWO
DOESN'T ALREADY DO.
THAT IF THEY TWENTY TWO WASN'T
THERE I WOULD UNDERSTAND
DEBATING THIS IS A HALF MEASURE
BUT BECAUSE HE TWENTY TWO WAS
THERE AND BECAUSE THIS BILL.
IS CONTINGENT ON THE ENACTMENT
OF THE TWENTY TWO I JUST DON'T
SEE THAT WE'RE WE'RE GETTING ANY
FURTHER BY PASSING BUT I THINK
YOU'VE HEARD OF FOR US.
ANSWERED THE QUESTION.
ANY ADDITIONAL QUESTIONS.
SEEING NO ADDITIONAL QUESTIONS
ANY CLOSING COMMENTS ABOUT THE
AUTHOR NO THANK YOU MUCH --
I I THIK THAT WE HAVE REALLY
ROBUST DEBATE AND A TWENTY TWO
THAT THE MEASURE IS SIMPLE AND
STRAIGHT PORT.
ARE SLIGHTLY ES WHEN I BOOKED.
BEFORE WE CAN GET. TWO AN AYE
VOTE WE WOULD NEED A FIRST AND A
SECOND.
I'LL MAKE THE MOTION.
WE NEED A PSYCHIC YOU MISS
CALENDAR.
WE HAVE A SECOND --
MADAM SECRETARY UP PLEASE CALL
THE ROLL.
POLLUTION IS DEPOSITED KAMALA
PRIVACY AND CONSUMER PROTECTION
SANTIAGO AYE AYE SANTIAGO AYE.
OBERNOLTE OBERNOLTE NO BONTA
CERVANTES.
CERVANTES AYE EDUARDO GARCIA.
ADVOCACY AYE HOLDEN.
HOLDEN I KAMLAGER-DOVE.
KAMLAGER-DOVE I LOW.
LOW I'M MAIENSCHEIN [inaudible]
MATHIS [inaudible]
PATTERSON [inaudible]
COKE'S OVER.
HOPE SILVA AYE [inaudible]
RODRIGUEZ [inaudible]
RODRIGUEZ I IF THE ONE MEASURES
OUT.
I WANT TO REMIND YOU THAT THE
MEETING IS NOT OVER SO I WOULD
ADVISE --
FOOD CORPSMAN HOUSE HAVE DID.
THAT YOU REFRAIN FROM CLAPPING
HER SCREAMING.
WELL HOLD THE RULE OPEN FOR
MEMBER STEP OUT ON FOR THE NEXT.
TWO MINUTES
ITEM NUMBER ONE S.
BEFORE SIXTY PATTERSON
[inaudible]
PATTERSON NO
.
ABOUT THIS YOU KNOW WHAT.
WE HAVE TO DO IT THIS WAY SO
THAT THERE IS NO TOGETHER.
I'M THE NUMBER ONE SP FOUR SIXTY
BONTA.
BONTA AYE [inaudible]
MAIENSCHEIN [inaudible]
MATHIS [inaudible]
MATHIS NO [inaudible]
YOU VOTER.
ITEM NUMBER TWO S. B. EIGHT TWO
TWO BONTA.
BONTA AYE [inaudible]
MATHIS [inaudible]
MATHIS NO
.
S. B. FOR SIXTY FINAL VOTE AND
NINE THREE S. B. A TWO TWO FINAL
VOTE.
NINE THREE MEETING IS ADJOURNED